com nous allons commencer pour cette
dernière réunion de l'année sur un un
thème dont nous avons eu l'occasion à
plusieurs reprises d'échanger entre nous
sans l'aborder d'une manière organisée à
travers une table ronde comme nous
allons le faire ce matin le thème vous
l'avez compris bien entendu c'est
l'intelligence
artificielle il y
a peu près un an le lancement par pour
le grand public de l'agent
conversationnel chat GPT a constitué
pour beaucoup une une révélation sur les
potentialités offertes par la une
révélation une prise de
conscience d'un fantasme d'ingénieur et
de futurologue nous sommes passés en
quelques mois à une réalité concrète
avec une application offrant un très
large éventail de de service au grand
public la délégation la prospective du
Sénat organisé le 7 novembre dernier
l'audition de d'un jeune écrivain
Raphaël dovant auteur de l'ouvrage si
Rome n'avait pas chuté la première
ucronie écrite et illustré grâce à chat
GPT les participants en ont retenu avec
des exemples concrets en direct les
capacités stupéfiante de l'IA capable
d'accomplir des tâches complexes parfois
indiscernables d'un travail humain dans
le même temps les IA sont devenus la
dernière mode si on peut le dire ainsi
pour les
investisseurs la société open ai serait
valorisé à près de 90 milliards de
dollars soit 20 milliards de plus que la
BNP les Français de Mistral ai avec 22
employés frôent les 2 milliards de
valorisation ces sommes littéralement
folles pour des outils qui n'ont pas
encore réellement de marché annonce
telle une révolution comparable à celle
de l'électricité ou d'Internet l'avenir
bien sûr nous le dira il est en tout cas
essentiel pour nous de nous intéresser
aux conséquences de l'IA sur les droits
d'auteur bien entendu et de manière
générale sur l'univers de la création
culturelle et artistique qui est en
première ligne il y a de semaines nous
avons reçu
avec Cédric Vial et Karine Daniel une
délégation d'artistes interprètes qui
nous ont présenté les menaces que le
développement des IA notamment dans le
secteur du doublage faisait peser sur
leur profession ce ne seront sans doute
pas les seuls à être concernés par cette
technologie témoigne de cette prise de
d'une part l'installation du comité pour
l'intelligence artificielle générative
par la première ministre le 19 septembre
dernier doté d'un groupe culture d'autre
part l'appel lancé le 17 novembre de
cette année par 79 organisations
représentant tous les secteur de la
création comment se positionne
aujourd'hui l'a face au droits d'auteur
il y a deux aspects d'un côté les IA
dites générative nécessite pour
s'entraîner un très grand nombre de
contenus de texte d'images et de sont
comment les droits d'auteur sont-ils
respectés comment s'opposer à cet usage
ou au contraire en tirer une juste
rémunération d'un autre côté Lesa
génèent des contenus que l'on peut
qualifier de culturels quel est le
statut de ces productions doivent-elles
faire l'objet d'une protection et au
bénéfice de qui le cadre juridique est
encore incertain il se construit au
moment même où nous parlons la directive
européenne du 17 avril 2019 sur les
droits d'auteur prévoit une exception
pour la fouille de données dans un cadre
de recherche de manière plutôt vague car
on n'imaginait pas à l'époque ces
gigantesques intelligence
artificielle la Commission européenne a
proposé un projet de règlement en avril
2021 après 4 années de débat un accord
semble avoir été trouvé entre la
Commission le Parlement européen et le
Conseil le 8 décembre c'est-à-dire la la
semaine il y a quelques jours les débats
ont été très virulents pour schématiser
au risque de caricature sur la question
spécifique deit du droit d'auteur ils
opposent les ayants droit unqu à juste
titre des conditions d'entraînement des
IA comme de leur impact sur le milieu de
la création et les entrepreneurs de l'IA
qui mettent en avant la nécessité elle
aussi
entendable de ne pas adopter une
régulation trop poussée susceptible de
faire rater à la France et à l'Europe le
train de la comme elle a raté celui
d'Internet et des réseaux sociaux il
reste à expertiser très finement le
texte du compromis qui peut d'ailleurs
faire l'objet d'évolution d'ici son
adoption définitive ce sera en partie le
travail de la commission des affaires
européennes du Sénat qui a décidé une
mission qui sera confiée à deux membres
de la commission culture en l'occurrence
Catherine main de sailli et
et et Karine Daniel c'est dans ce
contexte qu'intervient notre table ronde
nos invités vont nous permettre
d'entamer de la meilleure manière notre
réflexion et de bien positionner la
thématique propre à la création nous
avons le plaisir de recevoir ce matin
madame Alexandra bensamoun professeur de
droit privé à l'Université Paris Saclay
spécialiste de la propriété
intellectuelle et membre du comité de
d'intelligence artificielle
générative madameamoun est accompagné de
CIN représentants des des ayant droit
tous signataires de l'appel du 17
novembre et qui recouvre l'ensemble des
secteurs concernés Monsieur Pascal
Rogard directeur général de de la SACD
Monsieur David elsayeg directeur général
adjoint de de la sasem monsieur Renaud
Lefèvre directeur général du Syndicat
national de l'édition le SNE Monsieur
Thierry mayillard directeur juridique de
la Société des Auteurs dans les arts
graphiques et plastiques et Madame Julie
lorimi directrice générale du syndicat
des éditeurs de la presse magazine je
vais vous proposer en commençant par
vous madame Bens Samoun de nous aider à
bien comprendre les termes du débat en
ouvrant cette discussion pour une
dizaine de minutes et je demanderai
ensuite à chacun de nos intervenants de
nous présenter en en 5 minutes pas plus
pour qu'on puisse avoir un échange avec
vous par la suite les problématiques
liées à leur secteur leurs inquiétudes
et éventuellement leurs propositions
nous passerons après bien sûr mes chers
collègues à à aux questions que vous
souhaiterez poser j'ajoute pour être
complet que nous avons convier à
participer à cette table ronde d'autres
membres du comité de l'intelligence
artificielle générative dans le but de
diversifier les points de vue
malheureusement ni Cédric ha ancien
secrétaire d'État au numérique
reconverti je je continue si vous me le
permettez reconverti dans le conseil et
actionnaire de la société misrali nian
lecun un des pionniers de l'intelligence
artificiel et créateur du laboratoire de
MTA consacré au développement de ses
applications N entrepreneur président du
Conseil national du
numérique ne se sont rendus disponibles
pour intervenir ce matin mais nous
comptons bien entendu renouveler si
nécessaire notre invitation dans les
semaines à venir sans plus tarder madame
ben Samoun je vais vous laisser la
parole donc pour 10 minutes et puis
après chacun d'entre vous pour quelques
minutes je vous remercie monsieur le
Président Mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs merci de
accueillir aujourd'hui pour échanger
avec vous sur ce sujet technique
complexe mais euh aux influen et aux
conséquences très importantes
aujourd'hui déjà et demain encore plus
alors comme vous l' expliquer monsieur
le Président on est dans un cadre on est
dans le cadre de liage générative
aujourd'hui donc ce sont des
intelligences artificielles qui vont
ingérer beaucoup de contenu énormément
de contenus euh ces contenus sont
intégrés à ce qu'on appelle une base
d'entraînement et c'est en
déconstruisant euh ces contenus que le
système va dégager des règles qui
ensuite seront appliqué dans euh comme
un ordre en quelque sorte pour produire
un contenu donc on a une chaîne avec une
base d'entraînement cette ces contenus
dans la base d'entraînement sont
déconstruits des règles en sont inférré
et ensuite par exemple dans le chat GPT
vous faites un prompte et ce prompte va
appliquer les règles qui ont été dégagé
pour pouvoir produire un contenu qui
aura été généré comme on dit par cette
intelligence artificielle alors la
question qui s'est posée comme vous l'a
dit également monsieur le Président
c'est ces bases d'entraînement
contiennent énormément de contenus
culturels parce que les contenus
culturels sont des contenus de qualité
et donc ce sont des contenus qui sont
recherchés et il est aujourd'hui avéré
que un certain nombre de base
d'entraînement par exemple books 3
contenait des contenus non autorisés
donc des contenus
illicites intégré à cette base
d'entraînement et qui sont des bases
d'entraînement qui ont qui ont permis
l'émergence d'outils de de grands
modèles de langage tel que ceux qu'on
qu'on a cité aujourd'hui alors
quel est l'état du droit face à cette
situation la directive de 2019 la
directive droits d'auteur et droits
voisin dans le marché unique numérique a
mis en place deux exceptions au droits
d'auteur des exceptions de fouille de
texte et de données on dit en anglais
text and data mining des exceptions qui
ont été mises en place à une époque en
2019 où on ignorit complètement en tout
cas nous peut-être que d'autres ne
l'ignorent pas mais nous on ignorait
l'existence à venir de de de systèm de
grands modèles ou d'intelligence
artificielle à usage général qui
permettrai comme ça de générer une masse
de contenu et donc ces exceptions et
bien elles suspendent le droit de
reproduction pour cette opération en
amont de fouille de texte et de données
qui est l'opération qui correspond peu
ou prou à l'entraînement donc d'un
système diaia génératif
la première exception est une exception
réservée au secteur de la recherche
exception académique qui n'a pas fait
qui qui n'a pas été du tout contesté la
seconde exception elle est pour tous les
usages pour toutes les finalités y
compris la finalité commerciale c'est
une exception qui est apparu très
tardivement dans la discussion de
2019 dans un contexte où on était tous
très concentré vous vous souvenez sans
doute sur l'article 17 de la directive
qui rend le droit d'auteur et les droits
voisins réppos able aux plateformes
contributiv très concentré sur les
dispositions sur la rémunération très
concentré aussi sur les droits voisins
des éditeurs de presse bref des sujets
très importants et cette deuxième
exception commerciale et bien elle est
passée un peu sous les radars
elle est néanmoins assortie de
conditions pour pouvoir bénéficier de
l'exception de text and data mining pour
toute finalité et bien il faut un accès
licite au contenu d'abord et ensuite il
faut que les titulaires de droit n'ai
pas exercer leur droit d'opposition on
dit aussi on parle beaucoup et pardon
pour cela on parle beaucoup en anglais
on dit l'optout il ne faut pas que les
titulaires de droit a exercé leur optout
alors à partir de ces deux conditions
accès ilcite optout on en est où
aujourd'hui bah l'accès licite comme je
vous l'ai dit il est aujourd'hui avéré
que des grands modèles ont été entraînés
sur des bases qui contenaient des
contenus non autorisés donc illicites
donc la l'accès licite la condition
n'est pas remplie quant à l'optout
c'est-à-dire le droit d'opposition des
titulaires de droit c'est très compliqué
à exercer d'abord cet optout doit être
lisible par machine ce qui n'est pas
simple vu la multiplicité des des
exemplaires des des copies des contenus
qui se trouvent disséminés sur
l'Internet et qui sont pas
nécessairement mis en ligne par les
titulaire de droit par ailleurs on sait
que certains outils qui craollent des
contenus de toute façon écrasent les
métadonnées
donc un optout mais avec quelle
efficacité on doute hein de l'efficacité
de cette possibilité d'exercer l'optout
même si des solutions commencent à se
dégager mais c'est vrai que sont des
solutions techniques qui sont
compliquées quand même à mettre en œuvre
donc il va falloir beaucoup travailler
sur ce sujet sur la condition d'accès
licite là j'ai pas de solution hein s'il
est si si si elle n'est pas respectée
cela étant dans les deux cas tant la
condition d'accès licite que la
condition de droit d'opposition et et
bien elles ne pourront être vérifiées
que si les fournisseurs de système
d'intelligence artificielle sont
transparents la transparence a été
l'enjeu et a suscité énormément de
discussions dans la le trilogue sur l'ct
sur la proposition de règlement en cours
sur l'intelligence artificielle ça a
suscité beaucoup d'opposition et je dois
dire que j'ai été moi-même assez étonné
de ces oppositions par parce que la
transparence est un principe transversal
c'est un principe démocratique on nous
demande tous d'être transparent
d'ailleurs on demande aux entreprises de
tenir une comptabilité d'être
transparent le DSA le digital services
Act donc tous les derniers textes
européens sont fondés sur la
transparence et donc l'exigence de
transparence de la part des fournisseurs
d'intelligence artificielle me semble
som toute assez raisonnable et de bonne
logique pourquoi parce que tout
simplement elle va permettre d'exercer
les droits c'est-à-dire qu'elle va
donner une assise à cette exception de
texte un Data Mining pour pouvoir donner
à l'exception de fouille de texte et de
donner toute son envergure et bien
encore faut-il pouvoir vérifier les
conditions de cette exception la
transparence est donc la condition
essentielle il s'agit d'une question
d'équilibre il s'agit d'une question
d'applicabilité du droit déjà existant
hein il s'agit pas d'un ajout
supplémentaire mais juste de pouvoir
appliquer une exception qui a déjà été
adopté en 2019 par le par l'Union
européenne ce sujet n'est pas qu'un
sujet franco-français contrairement à ce
que certains peuvent penser il s'agit
d'un sujet international dans tous les
pays on s'inquiète on s'interroge de ce
fonctionnement un peu opaque de la
manière dont les IAS génératives ont pu
être entraînés il y a beaucoup de procès
en cours aux États-Unis dans tous les
secteurs de la culture euh musique
graphique graphique et plastique
littérature vous avez vu peut-être cet
auteur Andersen contre stability il y a
énormément de procès ce qui crée une
insécurité juridique pour le
développement de l'intelligence
artificielle et aussi pour son
implémentation hein dans de manière
générale dans tous les secteurs pourquoi
et bien parce que il y a de manière très
évidente un risque juridique aujourd'hui
sur ces outils parce qu'il y a un risque
juridique il faut aussi s'interroger sur
les conséquences sur le droit de la
concurrence pourquoi bah parce que
d'ailleurs la la FTC aux États-Unis
commence à s'y intéresser donc le
l'équivalent de notre autorité de la
concurrence commence à s'y intéresser
pourquoi parce que est-ce que le fait de
d'entraîner un système d' le fait de
fournir un système
d'IA donc entraîner sur des sources qui
sont illicites est-ce que ça n'est pas
une faute concurrentielle lorsque on est
déjà un acteur en position dominante la
question de la AB de position dominante
pourrait un jour se poser de ce
fait de la même façon se posera la
question du report des des
responsabilités on a des gros acteurs
qui ont donc fondé des des modèles des
grands modèles qui seront ensuite mis à
disposition de plus petits acteurs
économiques sans doute européens qui est
responsable de ce qui s'est passé en
amont il y aura-t-il un report des
responsabilité sur nos entreprises
européennes pour pour être complète mais
je sais que déjà le temps qui m'est
imparti est terminé pour être complète
le compromis qui a été arrêté vous le
savez au terme d'un trilogue qui a duré
35 he et qui a été très
éprouvant au niveau européen et il
semblerait que l'obligation de
transparence soit dans le texte je je je
personne n'a le texte définitif he pour
le moment et c'est normal hein il y a a
il y a une phase de de réunion tech
technique qui qui est en cours mais il
semblerait que l'obligation de
transparence a été reprise en revanche
d'autres inquiétudes peuvent se faire
jour notamment sur la définition même
d'un tout à l'heure j'ai utilisé le
terme de système d'intelligence
artificielle à usage général donc ces
espèces de grand modèle qu'on est en
train de créer puisque dans la
définition aurait été ajouté une mention
pour indiquer que la phase de recherche
la phase de développement la phase de
prototypage n'est pas comprise dans les
différentes obligations he qui qui ont
été mises à charge ensuite de ces
modèles donc il va falloir articuler un
petit peu tout ça articuler les textes
je me suis pardon concentré uniquement
sur l'amont vous avez raison monsieur le
Président l'aval sera aussi une question
qu'on devra se poser sans doute une fois
qu'on aura réglé l'amont c'est-à-dire
que fait-on d'une production générée par
une intelligence artificielle peut on y
appliquer le droit d'auteur si c'est
intégralement généré sans doute que non
parce que ici il y a un principe de
création humaine he le droit d'auteur
est réservé à l'humain mais pour autant
faut-il prévoir un autre
mécanisme peut-être une autre
réservation ou faut-il laisser le jeu du
contrat de la responsabilité civile
extra contractuelle qui vous le savez
est aussi en cours de révision au niveau
européen en cours de de forme de
discussion au niveau européen donc
beaucoup de de sujets qui se posent ici
on se concentre sur les sujets de droit
d'auteur mais on se concentrera et sans
doute vous aurez aussi à entendre les
sujets de données personnelles et cetera
tout t tous les droits toutes les
protections se poseront par rapport à
ces systèmes d'où l'importance aussi de
la transparence je vous remercie
monsieur le Président merci merci Madame
pour ce propos très clair et qui nous
permet de bien cadrer le débat je vais
donner la parole à Pascal Rogard pour 5
minutes
donc merci bah je ne serais pas aussi
brillant endroit qu'Alexandra parce que
c'est c'est sa spécialité et elle est
courageuse d'ailleurs d'être dans le
comité interministérielle parce qu'en
réalité elle est la seule à défendre la
création et je vais vous parler de ça
bon d'abord je suis heureux d'être au
Sénat parce que il y a une résolution
qui a été adoptée je crois que c'était à
l'initiative de Catherine main de et
d'utres sénateurs pour réguler
l'intelligence artificielle donc de
poser un principe de régulation mais il
y a pas que le droit d'auteur qui est
bien évidemment concerné je dois dire
que nous nous ne sommes absolument pas
opposés au développement de
l'intelligence artificielle parce que ça
peut être un outil positif pour enrichir
la création et avec des usages aussi
très intéressants pour la vie sociale en
mais on pense pas qu'il puisse se
développer au mépris du droit des
auteurs et de l' ensemble de ceux qui
financent la création or aujourd'hui je
le dis parce que c'est très grave c'est
la première fois que que je suis
confronté à ça depuis le temps assez
long où je m'occupe de ces questions de
de droit d'auteur pour la première fois
la France par la voix de Jean-Noël
barreot qui est je crois ministre du
numérique n'a pas été en soutien de la
culture de la création et du droit
d'auteur elle a même initié à Bruxelles
des rapprochements et des coalitions
avec des pays qui ne sont pas forcément
connu pour être les amis de la
régulation et droit d'auteur coalition
qui vise à créer ce qu'on appelle une
minorité de blocage pour empêcher le
texte qui a été adopté lors du trilogue
d'être complètement définitivement
adopté
elle menace donc de faire cette minorité
de blocage il y a plusieurs raisons
d'être déçu d'abord d'avoir entendu un
discours qui oppose systématiquement
innovation et la création la modernité
et le droit d'auteur je pense que le
droit d'auteur n'est n'a jamais empêcher
le le
développement des innovations et que ce
droit d'auteur je le rappelle ici c'est
une invention française c'est beaumarché
qui a créé la SACD mais qui a aussi
inventé le droit d'auteur ensuite et ça
c'est extrêmement grave il y a un
alignement complet total inquiétant de
la position française sur les intérêts
de la start-up Mistral dont l'un des
actionnaires cedrico ancien ministre en
charge du numérique et qui a fait objet
d'ailleurs de recommandations très
précises de la part de la Haute autorité
pour la transparence de la vie publique
nous nous interrogeons sur la compab la
compatibilité de ces activités et sur le
risque de conflit d'intérêts d'ailleurs
il est assez surprenant que dans le
comité stratégique sur l'intelligence
numérique dans lequel siège Alexandra il
y ait deux représentants de Mistral
de le président de Mistral monsieur
mench et Cédric qui est consultant mais
actionnaire aussi de de Mistral et le
lobbyiste de Mistral est-ce que on a
déjà vu dans ce genre de comité deux
représentants de la même
entreprise et ensuite il y a un problème
d'intérêt financier puisque monsieur
cedrico a obtenu c'est un article de
capital que j'ai laissé au président et
j'espère que ça sera distribué à tous
les sénateurs il a eu pour 16 16 € il a
acheté des actions qui sont valorisé à
23 million d'euros maintenant il en a
déjà revendu pour 1 million d'euros et
non pas toutes à des entreprises
européennes une partie a été revendue à
des entreprises extra européenne donc
c'est c'est quand même c'est très très
grave cette histoire je le Dison donc ce
que nous
demandons sur l'intelligence
artificielle et Alexandra a bien
expliqué là on discute surtout de la
partie entraînement
c'est la transparence parce que s'il y a
pas de transparence on peut pas exercer
cette exception un peu de d'optout et
nous nous voulons à tout prix faire en
sorte que le développement de
l'intelligence artificielle ce soit pas
une sorte de de piraterie généralisée
pour l'ensemble des des créations que ce
soit les créations audiovisuelles
musicales ou
l'édition littéraire alors les
entreprises qui développent
l'intelligence artificiel sont quand
même conscientes des risques parce que
il y a une déclaration très intéressante
des patrons de
Microsoft qui disent c'était en
septembre dernier ils apportent à leurs
clients une garantie de protection
juridique et ils endosseront la
responsabilité en cas de plainte pour
violation de propriété intellectuelle
vous savez qu'on vient vous apporter la
la protection dans certains films on
appelle ça c'est un peu mafieux mais
c'est quand même assez bizarre de voir
une entreprise une très grande
entreprise qui vous dit
déjà vous pouvez y aller
pirater je vous garantis contre les
risques et j'auraai les moyens de payer
les avocats pour vous
protéger ce discours qu'on entend
actuellement et qui est malheureusement
celui de la France ça rappelle
exactement le discours des gafas lors de
la directive droit d'auteur où on nous
disait sur l'article 17 Google qui
expliquait c'est une source d'insécurité
juridique qui pourra nuire au secteur de
la création et l'économie numérique en
Europe la directive a été adoptée elle a
été transposée et bien transposée et je
remercie encore le Premier ministre de
l'époque Jean Castex parce que la
directive a été transposée de façon
ambitieuse c'està-dire qu'on on a élargi
son champ sur certains points et pour le
moment j'ai pas constaté de dégâts sur
l'activité de Google de toute de toutes
ces
entreprises je dirais en plus que nous
et je pars là pour je pense toutes les
sociétés
d'auteur nous avons l'habitude de
traiter des données
confidentielles nous passons des
contrats avec des
entreprises comme
Netflix Amazon et ces contrats sont
couverts par par la confidentialité je
pense pas que nous ayons à jamais
portter atteinre à la confidentialité de
de ces constrats et donc nous nous
pensons que nous devons pouvoir assurer
la transparence avoir accès aux données
pour vérifier que il y a pas atteinte à
nos droits et ensuite on parlera des
produits parce que la thèse actuelle du
gouvernement français c'est de dire on
laisse libre
l'entraînement et on régule les produits
c'està ce qui sortira après et ce qui
sera offert au public et ce qui sera
commercialisé nous nous disons non il
faut au départ quand même avoir la
transparence pour contrôler ce qui se
passe éventuellement
empêcher empêcher d'avoir des données
dans certains cas même qui peuvent être
des données piratées et puis ensuite on
verra alors sur sur les les côtés je
dirais des
produit quand on entend le discours de
la France en disant il y a nulle part de
régulation je rappellerai que s'il y a
une régulation européenne elle
s'appliquera aussi aux entreprises
étrangères hors UE qui travailleront sur
notre territoire enfin sur le territoire
européen et de je conseille à tout le
monde de
lire les accords qui ont été passés à la
suite de grèv très importante entre des
acteurs audiovisuels aux États-Unis les
auteurs et les scén les les auteurs
scénaristes et les acteurs où il y a une
régulation très importante de l'IA
puisque alors là sur les produits
puisque à la fois les auteurs
scénaristes et les acteurs s'inquiètent
des utilisations de l'IA qui porteraent
atteinte à leur emploi hein parce que
toute une partie du développement de
l'IA peut porter atteinte aux emplois le
l'ancien patron de de d'une grande
entreprise d'animation Katzenberg
américaine a dit que dans le secteur de
l'animation du dessin animé liar
pourrait supprimer 90 % des emplois je
parle pas vous les avez reçu du doublage
du sous-titrage de la traduction c'est
déjà en cours donc voilà moi ce qui me
choque vraiment c'est que c'est la
première fois mais vraiment la première
fois que la France grâce à laquelle nous
avons la directive droit d'auteur parce
que lors de la premier vote au Parlement
européen la directive européenne avait
été repoussée et n'avait pas été votée
adopte pour pour la satisfaction d'une
seule
entreprise qui au final d'ailleurs sera
revendu aux Américains n'ayez aucun
doute euh une position contraire aux
droits d'auteur que nous avons inventé
voilà merci David elsayek pour la CSEM
sasem qui je crois déjà exercer le
l'option du
optout merci monsieur le Président mais
écoutez je suis d'accord a avec tout ce
qui vient d'être dit et donc je ne vais
pas le répéter mais je vais un peu
essayer de tenter d'expliquer
concrètement quel est pour nous les
enjeux et entrit à l'a alors comme tout
le monde personne n'est contre l'IA et
aujourd'hui nos créateurs utilise
l'intelligence artificielle comme outil
pour créer composer enregistrer mixer
donc c'est un outil qui est parfaitement
intégré chez les auteurs et dans le
secteur de la musique même la
prescription musicale quand vous êtes
abonné à un service de streaming c'est
aujourd'hui les outils d'intelligence
artificielle qui vous permettent de vous
aiguiller vers les artistes que vous
aimez ou vers les genres musicaux que
vous
affectionnez mais on est aujourd'hui
concrètement face à quelque chose de
totalement inédit en matière de droits
d'auteur on a vu les évolutions
techniques les modes de diffusion
internet arrivé les nouveaux modèles
économiques mais au fond tous ces
systèmes permettaient de voir que des
œuvres étaient exploitées et suffisait
pour une société d'auteur d'identifier
des œuvres puis après entrer en
négociation avec les exploitants alors
on a eu des difficultés et comme le
rappelait Pascal la directive de 2019
est venue corriger une asymétrie entre
les plateformes irresponsables et les
ayant droit mais on avait quand même un
système assez clair on voyait que des
gens exploitent des œuvres générai des
revenus qu'il fallait trouver des
solutions aujourd'hui avec
l'intelligence artificielle et les bases
d'entraînement qui ont été évoquées par
Alexandra on est face à une boîte noire
on ne sait pas ce qui est utilisé par
les outils d'intelligence artificielle
pour générer des contenus et je
n'appelle pas ça des œuvres puisque
c'est la machine qui intervient qui par
définition seront différents des œuvres
qui ont été été utilisé pour alimenter
l'intelligence artificielle donc moi je
veux bien bénéficier d'un d'un optout et
on l'a exercé parce que c'est l'outil
aujourd'hui qui est à notre disposition
et c'était la chose à faire restaurer
nos droits pour all négocier avec les
plateformes d'intelligence artificielle
mais si je ne sais pas ce que les ces
plateformes utilise pour générer des
contenus qui vont venir concurrencer les
œuvres créées par des vrais auteurs on
le sait il une forme de parasitisme
déployé par l'intelligence artificielle
qui viendra à moindre cûp créer des
images des textes des vidéos ou des
musiques on est face à une incapacité en
réalité de pouvoir mettre en œuvre les
droits d'auteur donc c'est l'avenir du
droit d'auteur qui se joue au travers de
l'obligation de transparence sans une
obligation de transparence
efficace applicable aux plateformes
européennes ou extraeuropéennes et le
texte aujourd'hui prévoit des
disposition qui fait en sorte que
n'importe quelle plateforme qui opère
sur le marché de l'Union européenne
devra satisfaire à certaines obligations
de transparence je vous le dis le droit
d'auteur ne servira à rien et donc je
suis tout comme Pascal désolé c'est
aussi la première fois j'ai moins
d'expérience que Pascal mais la première
fois que je vois ça que la France puisse
en réalité organiser un système qui
favorise l'opacité c'est de ça dont on
parle et c'est vraiment incroyable alors
qu'on s'est battu avec le gouvernement
pour une protection robuste du droit
d'auteur notamment dans le domaine
numérique qu'aujourd'hui au motif qu'il
existerait des sociétés performantes et
tant mieux elles vont pas mourir vu la
valorisation de Mistral je suis pas très
inquiet et comme l'expliquait aussi
Pascal les plateformes de partage de
contenu l'obligation de transparence n'a
pas nuit à leur développement elles
écrasent aujourd'hui le marché elles
sont regarder les jeunes avec TikTok ou
avec les réseaux sociaux on peut pas
croire que l'obligation de transparence
qu'impose la directive de 2019 les a
empêché de développer le leur modèle
économique donc c'est vraiment essentiel
pour nous un d'avoir cette obligation
transparent pour pouvoir négocier et
deux en aval parce qu'il y a aussi la
question de l'aval pour savoir si les
contenus qui sont générés par ces
intelligences artificielles mérit ou pas
la protection parce qu'entre un contenu
qui sera généré par de simples requettes
qui sera improtégeable par rapport à un
autre contenu qui aura nécessité des
promptes créatifs vous allez avoir des
différences et si les gens qui créent à
partir de l'IA qui utilise l'IA comme un
outil mérite protection on a aussi
besoin de cette obligation de
transparence donc voilà il y a un enjeu
fondamental il est pas que
franco-français mais malheureusement la
France joue un jeu dangereux par rapport
à l'avenir de la création j'en
terminerai par cela Renaud Le Fèvre pour
le Syndicat national de
l'édition je je je vais évidemment vous
essayer de vous épargner une
reformulation de tout ce qui a été dit
avec auquel j'adhère évidemment et les
éditeurs de livres adhèrent ad adhèrent
totalement
malheureusement je pense qu'il beaucoup
de sujets liés à lia qu'on aura pas
véritablement l'occasion d'aborder
aujourd'hui tant la question de la
transparence à par toutes les
énergies puisque c'est effectivement un
moment clé sur un un élément clé du
dispositif qui est en train de se jouer
nous ne sommes pas les uns les autres
des lanceurs d'alertes professionnels
mais la cause dont dont on vous parle
aujourd'hui est évidemment une cause qui
nous paraît tout simplement vitale
effectivement comme l'a dit David sur
sur laaven du droit d'auteur et donc
l'avenir de la création donc plutôt que
de reformuler je voudrais peut-être
venir rapidement sur et tenter peut-être
d'écarter un certain nombre d'objections
qui nous sont couramment opposées face à
ce discours qui est à la fois fondé sur
le droit sur la pratique et on va dire
sous une forme de bon sens et de
continuité naturelle par rapport à des
positions historiques qui ont toujours
été soutenis par la France alors
première objection moi j'en vois quatre
pour l'essentiel il serait pas possible
en fait d'identifier des des œuvres
sousdroit c'est très compliqué
apparemment pour les acteurs de
l'intelligence artificielle de de de
faire ça c'est assez
déconcertant une œuvre c'est identifié
par des caractéristiques des références
ce qu'on appelle des métadonnées je
voudrais juste rappeler que depuis des
décennies toute l'anonymisation de la
jurisprudence en France utilise des
outils de ce type c'est ce qu'on appelle
la reconnaissance d'entité nommées et ça
permet de reconnaître une adresse de
reconnaître un nom propre et de le
remplacer par des lettres donc ce sont
des technologies qui sont appliqué dans
certains domaines depuis plus de 10 ans
voilà donc elles ont peut-être été
oubliées par les acteurs de
l'intelligence artificielle mais on va
dire que cette argument semble d'une
portée quand même relativement
limitée deuxième argument l'optout ne
pourrait pas être respecté parce que les
le droit d'opposition ne serait pas
lisible par la machine alors là c'est un
argument qu'on pourrait presque
qualifier de risible pourquoi la
séquence droit d'opposition la séquence
no TDM la séquence optout serait la
seule séquence de caractère que les
moteurs d'intelligence artificielle ne
sauraient pas lire ils lisent tout mais
pas
ça 3ème objection bon tant bien même on
identifierait des contenus qui auraient
été d'une provenance
douteuse il serait impossible de les
soustraire de des des machines qui les
auraient déjà
digéré il y a un mois j'entendais Gil
Babinet s'exprimer sur l'évolution des
des outils d'intelligence artificielle
et expliquer comment fonctionnent ces
tils
sont des outils qui prennent des données
en entrée et qui contrôlent les
résultats en sortie quand on veut
améliorer les résultats en sortie il
faut modifier les éléments en entrée et
donc il faut retirer des données ou en
rajouter pour obtenir un résultat qui
semble plus adapté à ce qu'on cherche à
ce qu'on cherche à produire donc les
intelligences artificielles fonctionnent
par ajour retraite données c'est comme
ça que ça marche 4è argument on l'a dit
la transparence serait un frein à
l'innovation c'est effectivement
saisissant de voir la transparence
devenu une valeur négative alors on a
parlé d'une haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie politique passera
le regard à à à évoquer certains
éléments sur la constitution de certains
comités j'ajoute un élément qui a été
peut-être un peu moins visible il y a en
fait trois personnes N a Mistral dans
dans dans cette commission puisquil y a
également des membres du jury de thèse
de de du du
fondateur de de C de cette société donc
voilà tout tout ça pour dire que tout
ceci n'est pas euh
fait pour alimenter un climat de de de
de confiance la transparence on l'a dit
elle s'impose à tous la transparence
fiscale est imposée à tout le monde on a
même une association qui en fait son nom
Transparency International qui en fait
son nom et son enseigne pour porter la
valeur positive de la transparence et
les acteurs de l'intelligence
artificielle en seraient exempté au nom
de quoi au nom d'intérêts qui sont
censés être supérieur au droit d'auteur
au droits de propriété intellectuelle
c'est effectivement une une posture qui
qui est qui qui est saisissante juste
d'un mot pour dire deux choses
premièrement ça nous paraît aussi quand
on regarde l'évolution du de ce secteur
une erreur stratégique le train dont on
parlait des intelligences artificielles
génératives généraliste prête à à
produire du contenu sur tout et
n'importe quoi il est déjà parti il est
déjà parti depuis longtemps c'était
d'ailleurs sans doute un des passagers
clandestins de la discussion sur la
directive voilà parce que autant les
législateurs avaient probablement et on
peut le comprendre des difficultés à
percevoir ce qui allait se passer dans
les années suivantes autant je pense que
cette connaissance était bien acquise de
la part de de la part d'un certain
nombre d'acteurs la solution elle a été
dite c'est il s'agit d'avoir des des As
qualitatives qui s'entraînent sur des
données de qualité des données licites
et qui produiront des contenus de
qualité supérieure par rapport à des IA
générique et un dernier mot sur les
combats d'arrière-garde qui semblent
effectivement se mener pour amoindrir ou
en tout cas limiter les impacts du du
consensus lié lié au trilogue il serait
quand même extrêmement préoccupant et on
a on a utilisé des métaphores dans ce
sens dev voir s'organiser ce qu'on
pourrait appeler des des chaînes de
blanchiment de contenu
illicite alors voilà en considérant que
une fois que c'est passé quelque part et
qu'on n pas trop
regardé là on aurait des contenus sur
laquel effectivement les les les acteurs
n'auraient pas à rendre à rendre des
comptes donc vous l'avez compris
effectivement cet enjeul-là est un enjeu
qui est fondamental pour l'ensemble et
je pense que vous il est probablement
rare de de de constater une pareil
unanimité c'est vrai que le texte que
nous avons signé tous ensemble il y a
quelques temps en témoigne puisque c'est
vraiment un moment décisif qui se joue
en ce moment Thierry Maillard directeur
juridique de la Société des Auteurs dans
les arts graphiques et plastiqu je vous
remerci monsieur le Président donc je
vais vous parler effectivement de de la
situation des auteurs des arts visuels
donc les peintres les photographes les
designers les auteurs de BD les street
artistes les illustrateurs donc une
grande famille et qui c'est un secteur
qui le triste privilège aujourd'hui
d'être très directement concerné
concrètement aujourd'hui par par
l'émergence des des illages génératifs
puisque toutes ces œuvres sont
exploitées essentiellement sous forme
d'image et qu'on a des illages
génératifs d'images extrêmement
importantes sur le marché Dali
midjournée stable diffusion Adobe
Firefly et pour vous donner une idée du
déf ver leement de de création d'images
qu'on a sur 2022- 2023 les principales l
génératifs d'images ont généré un volume
d'imagees plus important que le nombre
de photographies qui ont été créées dans
les 150 premières années de la
photographie donc on est sur des volumes
qui sont extrêmement importants Dali
c'est 35 millions d'images par jour qui
sont créées Firefly il a d'adobi a
généré 1 milliard d'images dans les 3
mois de sa création donc on est sur des
volumes qui sont considérables et on
peut imaginer que dans quelques années
et peut-être même dans quelques mois on
aura plus d'images généré par des IA que
tout ce qui a été créé par l'humanité
auparavant donc il y a évidemment des
des éléments positifs à tout ça et les
auteurs peuvent utiliser l'a notamment
les auteurs de BD peuvent l'utiliser
pour créer des décors pour leur BD donc
ce qui leur fait gagner du temps donc
comme tous les autres secteurs on ne
remet pas en cause l'utilité sur le fond
de l'IA qui peut être effectivement
quelque chose de positive mais
clairement les dangers surpassent
aujourd'hui les les opportunités dans
notre secteur et on voit déjà des des
auteurs des air visuels qui sont menacés
directement dans leur activité
professionnelle par exemple des éditeurs
de livres qui vont y recourir pour faire
des couverture ou alors on a récemment
un horséri du monde avec une couverture
générée para où ça n'est donc pas un
illustrateur qui a été payé pour pour le
faire on a des magazines qui l'utilisent
aussi pour illustrer des articles et
tout ça ça permet de ne pas perdre de
temps avec un humain qui va avoir besoin
d'un peu de temps de création et qui va
en plus demander de l'argent il faut
avoir en tête qu'aujourd'hui le modèle
économique des i génér d'image c'est
soit la gratuité pour un nombre limité
d'œuvre soit des forfaits qui vont
permettre d'arriver à deux ou 3 centimes
d'euros par image donc en gros 10000
fois moins que ce que va demander un
auteur pour pouvoir créer son image et
juste pour pouvoir rentrer un peu dans
dans dans ses frais et pouvoir vivre de
de son activité donc tout ça ça soulève
des problématiques juridiques je dirais
qu'il y a d'abord des problèmes
politique et ceci est tô et c'est pour
ça qu' on est très heureux de pouvoir
s'exprimer devant vous puisque c'est la
question c'est de savoir quelle culture
on veut pour les générations à venir et
euh quels sont les emplois aussi qu'on
veut préserver hein je rappelle les
études qui ont été faites sur le poids
des en terme de chiffrre d'affaires et
d'emplois dans le domaine des industries
créatives qui est bien supérieur à ce
que peuvent générer les IA euh et donc
il faut avoir la euh le courage
d'intervenir il y a également une un
autre point à avoir en tête hein c'est
que les IA commencent à s'entraîner avec
leur propre production donc on est sur
quelque chose de totalement consanguin
et qui va euh euh devenir de plus en
plus important si on a plus d'auteur
pour créer de de vraies œuvres humaines
on va se retrouver avec quelque chose en
vasclos qui va nous créer une culture
dont on sait absolument pas à quoi elle
ressemblera sur les les les les
problématiques qu'on identifie c'est
essentiellement celle que je vais
évoquer celle de laamonde de l'input de
la fouille de données mais il y a
également sur l'aval beaucoup de choses
à dire dont on pourra discuter pour nous
les les les problèmes fondamentaux c'est
le consentement la rémunération et la
transparence transparence j'y reviendrai
pas parce que ça a été parfaitement
exposé jusqu'à présent euh et je
voudrais dire qu'il y a des solutions
qui relèvent du droit européen donc qui
nécessitent une modification du du cadre
européen mais d'autres qui peuvent
également se jouer au niveau national
par une intervention du législateur
national sur le consentement j'aimerais
revenir sur l'output parce que dans
notre secteur on a une vraie difficulté
euh Alexandre bensamoun l'a rappelé la
première condition de l'exception de
fouille de données général c'est l'accès
licite c'est vrai que dans beaucoup
d'autres secteurs la musique
l'audiovisuel euh le texte aussi quoi
les les livres la presse on a euh un
contrôle de de ce qui est euh euh euh
diffusé au public et en général bah
j'imagine que si on va sur des sites
Lego de de de streaming de musique ou de
VOD on va pas pouvoir arriver et
télécharger tout ce qui se présente sur
le site on va d'abord se loguer
s'inscrire et puis pouvoir accéder ça ça
bloque les IA ça bloque les robots des
IA en matière d'image c'est
inenvisageable cont tenu des usages qui
se sont installés que quand vous allez
sur le site du Centre Pompidou ou sur un
site de presse il y a pas d'image du
tout qui apparaissent donc on n'a pas
ces mesures techniques déjà qui sont le
premier filtre et le législateur
européen avait une vision simpliste des
choses en se disant non de toute façon
l'auteur qui est pas content il suffit
qu'il mettre des mesures techniques
autre autre vision simpliste c'est les
dispositifs lisibles par la machine
puisque la directive nous dit que les
auteurs peuvent s'opposer pour les
exploitations en ligne avec des procédés
liisibles par la machine le problème
c'est que encore le législateur a pas eu
en tête que généralement les auteurs en
tout cas dans notre secteur ne sont pas
les diffuseurs de leurs œuvres donc ils
ont pas la main sur les serveurs des
sites qui diffusent leurs œuvres et ils
peuvent pas aller courir après 10000
sites qui vont avoir diffusé à chaque
fois une de leurs œuvres pour leur
demander de faire des réglages alors
qu'en plus ces procédés sont pas du tout
aujourd'hui suffisamment mû pour pour
agir donc il y a plusieurs solutions et
je vais pas rentrer dans le détail mais
on pourra y rentrer après je pense que
la plus simple entre guillemets ce sera
déjà dacté que l'article 4 de la
directive n'est pas applicable aux IAS
génératives aux autres y potentiellement
mais ça a été dit elles ont pas du tout
été on les avait pas à l'esprit quand ça
a été créé et on a des arguments très
forts euh des instruments internationaux
et le test en trois étapes qui fait que
si on n'est pas sur quelque chose qui
est un cas spécial on pourrait l'écarter
et de mon point de vue ça pourrait
s'écarté au niveau national puisque la
France doit appliquer le test en trois
étapes et qui est imposé de toute façon
par la directive elle-même deuxème point
si on on dit que malgré tout l'exception
s'applique aux ID générativ il faudrait
qu'on ait un optout effectif et qu'on
nit pas ce cette espèce d'invention tout
à fait théorique que les auteurs vont
agir sur chaque site mais qu'on ait des
solutions qui permettent à un auteur de
pouvoir PIR faire une opposition
générale pour toutes ces œuvres et que
plutôt que ce soit les auteurs qui
courent après les sites pour faire cet
optout technique que ce soit les
plateformes qui doivent venir voir ce
que veut faire les auteurs et ça ça peut
passer par les organismes de gestion
collective ou par d'autres moyens plus
centralisé et qui permettrait d'avoir
cette information et enfin la vraie
faille qu'on a également dans le
dispositif de la directive c'est qu'il y
a pas d'obligation de désapprendre c'est
une exception au au droit de
reproduction mais donc une fois que les
IA ont reproduit les œuvres on dit gérer
ont pris tout l'esprit des œuvres elle
ell supprime souvent les œuvres et tout
ce qui est dans leur intelligence ben
même si on fait un uptout on va pas
pouvoir leur dire vous devez tout
lesésapprendre donc pour le répertoire
de laadagp je pense que tout est déjà
ingurgité et digéré par les par les IAS
si on fait un optout de toute façon il y
a que les œuvres nouvelles qui seront
créées donc il y a sur l'optout il y a
beaucoup de choses à faire et et
beaucoup de problèmes mais
éventuellement même au niveau national
on pourrait intervenir et je termine sur
la question de la rémunération on a un
vrai problème aujourd'hui de partage de
la valeur je disais les auteurs sont
concurrencés sur leur propre marché par
des contenus générés par EA et qui ont
été générés grâce à leurs œuvres là on a
une vraie difficulté et là encore on a
des moyens d'agir que ce soit par la
mise en place éventuellement d'une
compensation équitable qui là aussi
résulterait du test en trois étapes et
évidemment il s'agit pas d'empêcher la
la vraie solution la vraie voie normale
c'est d'arriver sur des licen donc
l'optout permet de passer des licences
on pourrait parfaitement avoir un
mécanisme de compensation qui soit
supplétif c'est-à-dire en l'absence de
licence on pourrait avoir une
compensation équitable là encore il y a
des solutions qui pourraent être
envisagées et enfin sur sur l'output il
également et nous on le voit très
concrètement les auteurs nous disent bah
aujourd'hui je perds des contrats donc
comment je vais faire pour pouvoir vivre
malgré cesia une solution qui est très
intéressante et et et qui a été
développée par par la doctrine et
notamment un très bon article de Valé
Benabou sur le sujet qui a été publié la
semaine dernière c'est sur le domaine
public payant c'est-à-dire d'avoir sur
ces ces œuvres qui n'ont pas d'auteur
physique créateur de la forme d'avoir de
pouvoir dire si elles sont pas attribué
à un auteur personne physique on va
considérer qu'elles sont dans le domaine
public ce qui empêche de faire des
exclusivités déjà donc ce qui est moins
intéressant pour les utilisateur parce
que si l'œuvre est réutilisée il
pourront pas agir et puis s'il était
payant ce domaine public ça permettrait
de pouvoir répartir derrière alors
évidemment c'est des choses qui sont
pour l'instant théoriques et il faut
évidemment creuser et voir ce qui est si
ça s'il y a pas des effets collatéraux
et si c'est quelque chose qui est
envisageable mais il y a quand même
matière à pouvoir réfléchir à des
solutions aujourd'hui pour sur sur ces
questions d'IA générative et je ne parle
que d'IA générative les IA de manière
générale sont pas aussi dangereuses pour
pour les en tout cas pour les auteurs de
des air
visuels Julie lorimi pour le syndicat
des éditeurs de la presse magazine oui
je vous remercie pour de me donner la
parole et merci pour cette invitation et
et et l'organisation de cette table
ronde euh donc le le SEPM pour ceux qui
pardon le SEPM peut-être euh tous ne le
connaissent pas c'est un un syndicat
d'éditeurs de press magazine donc aussi
bien de la presse euh d'information
politique général que de la presse à
centre d'intérêt culturel euh euh pour
pour la presse pour les enfants
également euh on a une grande diversité
de de d'éditeurs de press magazine au
sein de notre syndicat euh tous sont
extrêmement inquiets de l'évolution de
l'évolution de ce dossier
euh je je voudrais euh je voudrais dire
en premier lieu que on on est ici au
côté des représentants des industries
culturelles et c'est tout à fait normal
nous en sommes une bien entendu mais les
impacts pour nous sont à la fois
effectivement des impact économique
comme comme nous tous et ils sont
importants j'aimerais y revenir et puis
il y a également des des impacts
je dirais sur le le champ informationnel
dont on parle beaucoup par ailleurs dans
le cadre des États généraux parce que
vous savez qu'on on parle beaucoup de
fiabilité de l'information actuellement
notamment dans le cadre des États
généraux voulus par le par le Président
de la République donc je vais essayer
d'être un petit peu peut-être concrète
sur comment l' attaque puisque je pense
qu'on est l'un des secteurs enfin on est
tous extrêmement concerné en tout cas en
ce qui concerne la presse on le vit là d
au aujourd'hui comme presque une
amplification de de de de phénomène de
phénomène
antérieur donc revenir peut-être un
petit peu sur la façon dont dont l'IA
peut
attaquer
notre modèle économique lui-même déjà
très fragilisé aujourd'hui et puis
ensuite parler de de des approches des
approches juridiques qui peuvent être
différentes euh je crois autour de la
table et c'est bien normal mal un mot en
préambule pour vous dire que nous
partageons à 100 % ce qui vient d'être
exprimé ici sur la façon dont dont la
décision publique est prise aujourd'hui
et que c'est un c'est un facteur de
grande inquiétude vous avez cité
l'article de challenge donc
effectivement c'est un de nos adhérents
et il est extrêmement
chocquants les éléments qu'il qu'il
comprennent sont extrêmement choquants
s'ils sont s'ils sont avéré je crois
qu'on va beaucoup parler de transparence
aujourd'hui donc transparence des IAS
mais aussi transparence euh de la de
notre vie publique euh et nous dès la
constitution du comité interministériel
je dois dire que nous nous sommes
beaucoup émus euh indépendamment même de
la présence de Mistral ai du parti prix
qui a consisté euh à ne pas réunir
uniquement des purs esprits hein des des
chercheurs d'éminents professeurs mais
aussi cette idée qu'on y intègre des
représentants d'intérêt hein et que ces
représentants d'intérêt peuvent être
représentants d'intérêt d'ailleurs de
sociétés qui qui ne sont pas européenne
et puis des représentants d'intérêts
totalement incomplets puisqueen fait on
a les représentants d'intérêt en masse
de la tech et de l'IA et absolument pas
aucun c'est quand même incroyable on a
aucun représentant d'intérêt puisquon on
peut assumer d'être d'être désigné comme
tel du monde culturel ou du monde de
l'information et des médias zéro voilà
donc heureusement on a des défenseurs du
droit d'auteur des défenseurs de la
presse enfin un défenseur une déf mais
pardon mais mais aucun représentant des
intérêts des médias et de la culture
c'est c'est donc un parti prix qui dès
le départ risque de biaiser les
propositions qui seront fait dans dans
ce comité même si on on est entendu et
on le sera encore dans ce comité mais je
je partage donc absolument toutes les
les toutes les remarques précédentes sur
sur ce point euh pour pour parler
concrètement nous la presse vous le
savez on est un un secteur qui est dans
un grand paradoxe c'est-à-dire qu'on est
à la
fois on enregistre une très forte
audience je crois que jamais nous
concitoyens n'ont autant lu de presse et
puis en même temps on a un chiffre
d'affaires divisé par deux en 20 ans on
passe de de 4 milillard 8 à 200
milillards 7 entre 2001 et
2021 mais on a
2,4 milliards de pages vues chaque mois
de pages de presse vu chaque mois et on
a un français sur de qui déclare lors de
du sondage vous savez le sondage très
régulier que fait la croix sur les
Français et la presse la confiance dans
les médias et cetera donc ce sondage
dans le dernier la dernière enquête
terrain qui a été qui a été faite montre
que un Français sur deux euh chaque jour
s'informe via la presse écrite qu'elle
soit évidemment sur format digital ou
format ou format papier donc on a un
modèle qui qui qui qui suscite de la
pétence qui semble indispensable à nos
concitoyens mais qui en même temps est
en recherche de modèle économique donc
aujourd'hui le modèle économique sur le
digital je voudrais y revenir parce que
c'est important pour comprendre comendre
ce qui se passe avec les IA le modèle
économique sur le Digital est
extrêmement difficile à trouver euh
certains magazines finance leur partie
digitale encore avec leur activité
papier euh ce qui pourrait presque être
ENF qui qui qui qui qui peut nous
questionner ce modèle digital il est
fondé sur quoi il est fondé sur le
trafic qui est apporté enfin le trafic
des sites de presse donc l'audience des
sites de presse qui détermine elle-même
le revenu publicitaire et les
abonnements à la presse hein on peut pas
envisager aujourd'hui que il puisse y
avoir des abonnements et des revenus
publicitaires sans sans trafic sur les
sites de de presse en ligne
euh par la force des choses et c'est
comme ça pour absolument tous les sites
hein y compris je sais pas les sites du
gouvernement les sites de du Sénat le
site de l'Assemblée les les les les les
internautes passent souvent très très
souvent par des plateformes notamment
des moteurs de recherche pour ensuite
être conduit via des liens euh à ces
sites euh la transformation des éditeurs
de presse elle se horte aujourd'hui au
fait que la quasi-ttalité des revenus
euh
publicitaires sont captés euh par ces
très grandes plateformes moteurs de
recherche et cetera or ces revenus ils
sont générés en partie et c'est là où où
on a une difficulté ces revenus sont
générés en en partie évidemment pas que
mais en partie par les contenus de
presse euh c'est les contenus enrichis
que vous trouvez sur des moteurs de
recherche ou que vous trouvez sur des
plateformes même avec des soit des
reproductions intégrales soit des
parties de d'articles de presse avec
parfois des
photos et cetera et et des
liens donc le le le droit voisin et et
c'est là on peut mesurer l'étendue euh
de l'évolution de la position française
puisque pas plus tard qu'en 2019 le
gouvernement français soutenait le
législateur qui lui-même transposait
extrêmement rapidement euh la directive
droits voisin donc c'était il y a à
peine quelques années on avait une
position extrêmement claire favorable à
la protection des des éditeurs de presse
euh et on mesure le effectivement une
évolution très très préoccupante dans
les positions gouvernementales
euh donc pour pour pour compenser en
fait le transfert de valeur sur ses
revenus publicitaires notamment euh le
droit voisin euh est venu euh euh a été
reconnu par le législateur en 2019 avec
la vocation de rééquilibrer ce transfert
de valeur et également de rémunérer la
reprise des contenus enrichis mis en
avant par les plateformes et dont il est
établi qu'elle détourne une bonne partie
du trafic sur nos sites de
presse aujourd'hui on a cette même
problématique de détournement de trafic
et et donc d'audience et donc de revenus
publicitair et d'abonnement et de donc
de modèle économique qui intervient avec
le développement de ces services de
Dia qui propose de l'information ou en
tout cas qui propose des
contenus qui ressemblent beaucoup à des
contenus de
presse et qui et qui ne paye pas on l'a
vu ne rémunère pas et ne participe pas
au coûts colossaux d'une rédaction et de
d'un globalement de la constitution de
la fabrication d'un magazine je voudrais
rappeler qu'aujourd'hui la fabrication
des des magazines de presse c'est à la
fois une rédaction coûteuse par nature
c'est bien normal mais aussi des
développements technologiques colossaux
extrêmement important c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que opposer innovation et et
et et et acteur traditionnel n'a n'a
aucun sens et on a donc des modèles type
Bard chat GPT
qui propose des des des des articles
synthétiques euh sans participer
aucunement à la fabrication très
coûteuse de ces de ces articles les plus
préoccupants aujourd'hui encore on a des
perspectives d'intégration de ces za à
des plateformes ou à des moteurs de
recherche vous avez par exemple aux
États-Unis un service qui se développe
qui est en test par Google qui qui
s'appelle search générative expérience
et qui propose d'intégrer au search
lui-même donc au moteur de recherche le
service dia dia génératif qui propose
des instantané ou des résumés euh on lui
est place des actuels snipets qui
aujourd'hui proposait des liens et bien
aujourd'hui ces services ne proposent
quasiment soit pas de lien du tout soit
un lien qui est accessible très
difficilement et qui n'est pas cité
comme une source le lien vers l'article
de presse mais qui est cité un petit peu
pour corroborer les informations
synthétiques qui auront été données euh
par par le moteur de recherche bien
évidemment le la captation du trafic la
captation de l'audience est absolument
redoutable dans le cas de ces services
di générativ intégrés au moteurs de
recherche ou aux grandes plateformes euh
elle augmente évidemment
considérablement le risque que les
utilisateurs n'aillent plus du tout sur
le site de presse puisqu'ils ont euh la
réponse à leurs questions euh sur le le
le sur le le moteur lui-même ou sur la
plateforme elle-même et je vous je vous
enjoins à à à lire un article
euh un article récent euh dans la presse
américaine qui montre que dans ces
cas-là euh 75 % des utilisateurs
n'iraient pas cliquer sur le site de
presse alors maintenant je voudrais en
venir quelques instants très rapidement
sur
euh le fait que ce que je vous décris là
c'est évidemment une menace absolument
existentielle pour la pour la presse il
y a pas de doute euh je voudrais dire
aussi petit incist que à l'heure où le
droit voisin n'est pas encore effectif
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui nous press
magazine un seul et unique opérateur
redevable du droit voisin rémunère
rémunère la presse donc on on on est
alors même que le droit voisin n' n'a
absolument pas déployé toute l'ampleur
pour laquelle à laquelle vous vous
attendiez hein vous
législateurs et bien on est face à cette
menace très très puissante totalement
existentielle pour nous et là je me
permets de dire que cette menace
existentielle pour la presse est aussi
une menace pour le fonctionnement des
États démocratiques qui sont fondés sur
un un débat public de qualité avec des
informations fiables vérifiées
intermédia qui ont fait l'objet d'un
traitement
journalistique il faut rappeler ici que
la matière première de la presse euh
n'est pas c'est pas la une pure création
de l'esprit comme il peut y en avoir
dans d'autres secteurs culturels hein
elle s'appuie sur les données du réel
qui vont ensuite être traité par un
journaliste et ce réel et bien il faut
aller le chercher il faut aller
l'éprouver il faut aller le tester il
faut aller le vérifier c'est le travail
du journalisme
euh cela se fait dans des conditions
parfois très très difficiles et
j'aimerais dire un mot sur j'aimerais
dire un mot sur cette nécessité
d'intermédiation par le journalisme et
de vérification par le journalisme euh
dont on peut mesurer aujourd'hui euh
l'ampleur de la de l'absolue nécessité
sur on a des guerres
actuellement on peut imaginer ce que
serait l'information dans dans des temps
effectivement de propagande de
manipulation de l'information on peut on
peut imaginer ce que serait
l'information si elle n'était faite que
de tweet de cobelligérant et s'il n'y
avait pas ce travail de recherche
d'intermédiation de traitement de
formation et de mise en perspective par
les médias
euh on serait donc dans des risques de
manipulation et de
propagande renforcée
accentué je je je je j'espère puisque
les États généraux dans les états
généraux de l'information le président
de la République a répété que l'Ance
c'était la
fiabilité de l'espace informationnel et
qu'il fallait garantir au français une
liberté une indépendance et une
fiabilité de l'information on est au
cœur du sujet on peut pas envisager unea
non qualitative avec des sources qui ne
seraient pas des sources de qualité
vérifié et j'en viens et c'est j'arrête
là parce que je crois que j'ai dépassé
les 5 minutes ou ou oui oui je je juste
deux points largement
absolument du double effet absolument
pour parler du double effet sur les S
citoyen d'unea qui serait non régulé qui
ne serait pas transparente il y aurait
un premier effet effectivement sur des
services de presse des et des et des
éditeurs qui seraient exang et ne
pourrai plus assumer les coûts
importants du journalisme premier effet
deuxième effet on aurait aussi desa qui
elle-même serait constitué de
d'informations fauses manipulé non FiBL
et qui aurait donc qui proposerait
elle-même également au lecteur donc
double double préjudice 10 pour
l'électeurs et les citoyens puisque les
LESIA elle-même ne pourrai pas proposer
cette information fiable voilà donc la
perspective d'une d'une information de
dire ben finalement aujourd'hui on va
s'informer grâce aux za et cetera c'est
c'est c'est ce n'est absolument pas ni
pragmatique ni réaliste merci mes chers
collègues je vais vous maintenant
laisser la parole on va prendre toutes
vos interventions donc n'hésitez pas à
noter parce qu'il y aura des points sans
doute
sur lequel vous aurez à réagir et
apporter des réponses on va commencer
par Catherine main de
sailli merci beaucoup Président je
voudrais d'abord tous et toutes vous
saluer votre éclairage est très
essentiel au stade où nous sommes de
cette régulation de de Lia saluer les
propos de Pascal Rogard qui a rappelé
quelque chose de bon sens qui est de
dire que la elle est ni bonne ni
mauvaise elle dépend de l'usage que nous
allons en faire c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut réguler d'emblé euh
tout le secteur c'est tout à fait
essentiel et et le règlement Ia européen
c'est le triptique c'estf c'est le
troisème volet d'un triptique DSA DMA
que l'on doit à Thierry Breton auquel il
faut associer le Data qui est encore de
en cours de discussion dans le trilogue
qui est très important parce que c'est
la première fois qu'une législation se
met en place sur l'IA au niveau mondial
donc comme le rgpd et en quelque sorte
l'é talon d'or c'est une référence pour
nombre de pays à travers le monde le
règlement il a le sera tout autant donc
l'Ance c'est que justement il soit
équilibré qu'il permettent l'innovation
tout en garantissant la nos droits
fondamentaux et comme vous l'avez évoqué
la la transparence alors comme l'a
évoqué le président notre commission des
affaires européennes qui étudie sous à
l'initiative de Jean-François Rapin tous
les textes de règlement européen pour
que nous puissions formuler des
propositions de résolution européenne ou
des avis politiques qui remontent bien
en Amond au Parlement européen puisse se
faire et bien nous avons traité chacun
de ces sujets et et il a avec mon
collègue André gatolin elsachal et
Cédric Vial nous avons rendu comme l'a
expliqué euh euh Laurent Lafond un avis
euh sur l'IA bien conscient des dangers
que vous avez évoqué je dois dire que
euh la Commission prend en compte nos
avis et c'est sur l'ensemble des textes
donc on a un dialogue satisfaisant et
que ça rejoignait tout à fait les les
les préoccupations du Parlement européen
qui a bien renforcé la question du droit
d'auteur je crois que vous vous en vous
en
conviendrez le problème c'est que le
trouble a été jeté par le fameux Cédric
ha qui siège dans le Comité
intergouvernemental qui a encore
beaucoup d'influence auprès notamment du
président de la République et qui de
toute éternité défend avant tout les
intérêts d'acteurs extra-européens on se
souviendra de l'affaire de la plateforme
des données de santé Microsoft et cetera
je vais pas
revenir dessus donc ce qui est troublant
en effet c'est sa participation à ce
comité vous avez signalé aussi la
participation de certains membres j'ai
vu qu'il y avait des membres de Facebook
enfin de Méa hein qui siège dans ce ce
ce comité donc c'est en effet un peu un
peu surréaliste maintenant je je pense
que tout est bien qui finit à peu près
bien c'est vous qui pouvez nous le dire
puisque que le trilogue semble-t-il
atterri sur un texte qui reprend un
certain nombre de préoccupations du
Parlement européen ou sinon vous allez
nous le dire car il est encore temps que
notre commission des affaires
européennes et je vois Karine Danel qui
est notre nouveau rapporteur ma nouvelle
corapportrice sur ces sujets que
ensemble on puisse dès début janvier
formuler un un avis qui remonte très
vite à l'heure où les le texte se
stabilise dans l'ensemble pour
l'ensemble des des États-membres c'est
important qu'on puisse jouer notre rôle
et et et et et vous et vous aider voilà
le rôle de Cédrico est tout à fait
scandaleux d'ailleurs je poserai une
question d'actualité là-dessus cet
après-midi cet enrichissement personnel
cette confusion des genres ce conflit
d'intérêt a été et assez sérieux pour
que Thierry Breton lui-même le tacle à
travers l'épingle à travers la presse
vous l'avez remarqué et disent qu'ils
défendaiit tout sauf l'intérêt
général
daniel Merci euh évidemment je je
souscris complètement à à au propos de
de ma
corapporteur ma collègue Maurin de
sailli on est on est tous préoccupés par
cette question de transparence et on
reste très vigilant et et mobilisé après
au-delà moi mes mes
interrogations c'est euh la question
avec le le déploiement et la massif
ication de l'utilisation de l'IA comment
est-ce qu'on peut gérer des questions de
contrôle quels sont les moyens à
déployer pour effectuer ces contrôles et
qui va être en capacité de les faire et
ensuite en cas de recours on voit bien
qu'on aura un problème d'asymétrie entre
des acteurs qui sont très concentrés et
des auteurs ou des producteurs qui sont
eux par contre en très grand nombre et
donc là on va avoir un problème de de
rapport de force dans dans le recours et
dans le et et dans cette phase
éventuelle de de recours et et et cette
asymétrie c'est un vrai sujet pour nous
et
puis l'autre point qui qui m'inquiète et
sur lequel on doit être vigilant lié
aussi à la massification et au caractère
au développement
exponentiel de l'utilisation de ces
techniques c'est la vitesse de création
de valeur qu'on retrouve dans le cas
qu'on a cité et et qu'on va retrouver de
manière j'imagine encore plus importante
pour d'autres acteurs et là encore on a
une grande asymétrie vous le disiez
madame entre le fait que le modèle
économique est très difficile à trouver
pour les créateur de contenu et et et à
l'inverse on va avoir de la création de
valeur exponentielle et on le voit déjà
et les premiers les premiers retours sur
investissement qu'on peut qualifier
quand même de d'assez intéressant pour
ceux qui euh euh en sont à la source là
on a un problème de de régulation
manifeste et donc là je pense que c'est
au législateurs c'est au régulateurs
européens de considérer aussi ces enjeux
d'asymétrie pierre
uyas merci monsieur le Président merci
pour la qualité de votre propos moi j'ai
j'ai questionné là tout de suite
l'intelligence artificielle sur notre
question donc je je vous donne la
réponse la réglementation de liia est un
sujet complexe qui nécessite une
approche équilibrée pour maximiser les
avantages de l'IA tout en minimisant les
risques associés lia parle comme un
sénateur hein c'est c'est
ou alors peut-être que j'ai une version
spéciale pour moi membre de l'opposition
ce que ce que je remarque quand même
c'est que l'intelligence artificielle a
plus de raison humaines que des humains
qui mettent leur intelligence au service
de l'artifice et ça renvoie directement
à à ce qu'on vient de dire moi
j'aimerais vous vous vous entendre sur
un sujet qui sur lequel le Sénat
travaillait avec Lord D'cos nous avons
travaillé sur la science ouverte et sur
la façon dont certains grands éditeurs
privés dans le domaine de l'édition
scientifique sont en train de de
constituer une intelligence artificielle
à partir des données scientifiques qui
la rassembleent avec les articles de les
auteurs lesquels articles scientifiques
sont financé par l'État via les
processus du modèle diamant de la
science ouverte je rentre pas dans le
dans le détail donc nous sommes dans
dans un système complètement
complètement incroyable où c'est l'État
lui-même qui finance la capacité
d'acteur privés à pouvoir par
l'intelligence artificielle produire
demain pour pour les futurs
États des conseils des services qui sont
basés sur les données de la recherche
publique voà et avec Lord D'cos nous
avions montré dans notre rapport que
derrière le projet de la science
ouvererte développée par le ministère de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche il y avait une forme
d'hirénisme
d'angélisme absolu et que le le le
ministère ne ne voyait pas quelle était
la véritable intention l'intention c'est
pas évidemment de mettre la science à
disposition de tout le monde non
l'intention qui est qui est cachée
derrière c'est de de constituer des
futurs mastodontes euh qui auront euh
euh quasiment les mêmes ressources que
les grands acteurs que euh que vous euh
que vous avez cité euh je je pense qu'il
y a là un danger réel euh pour l'édition
pour l'édition euh privée et euh madame
vous avez publié chez euh Maré Martin
euh qui est pas très loin d'ici
euh notamment notamment pardon pardon
pardon notamment euh et et ça c'est
c'est c'est vraiment euh des petites
maisons d'édition qui rendent un service
euh extrêmement important à l'édition
scientifique qui dont le modèle
économique risque d'être complètement
compromis euh par les évolutions que que
vous avez indiqué euh donc notre rapport
avec Lord Arcos euh n'a pas tellement
connu euh de suite hein
euh euh euh pour l'instant on attend
encore euh une évolution euh du du
ministère de lenseignement ce pas il y
aurait de la recherche sur ce demande
euh comment vous pourriez nous aider
pour qu'il y ait une prise de conscience
un peu plus prononcée forte des danger
auquel nous nous soumettons nous-mêmes
et notamment avec l'argent des
contribuables ce qui ce qui est quand
même un un réel problème je
remercie Lord Arcos
justement non non pas du tout mais c'est
c'est on fait toujours notre tendemme de
choc
euh je vais pas reparler du même sujet
que que Pierre moi je je voulais vous
poser un peu à tous la question
concernant l'op-tin parce qu'on parle
beaucoup de l'optout mais finalement
est-ce que pour mieux rémunérer en fait
l'ensemble des des
créateurs on pourrait pas essayer de
plutôt essayer de trouver des sujets en
amont ce qui depuis tout à l'heure ce
qui me frappe je je regarde Pascal mais
d'autres c'est quand même dingue qu'on
se retrouve encore à nouveau aujourd'hui
à parler de tout ça euh et que on a eu
tellement tellement d'énergie dépensé
pour la directive droit d'auteur à
Bruxelles et qu'aujourd'hui on se
retrouve avec tous ces acteurs qui ne
faisaient pas partie bien évidemment de
nos négociations parce qu'il n'existait
pas je parle de TikTok avant même
l'intelligence artificielle et
aujourd'hui tous ces gens sont bien sûr
enfin toutes ces instances sont en
dessous des radars mais je je c'est pas
que je me décourage mais c'est vrai que
on avit pensé d'énergie à l'époque
aujourd'hui il faut de nouveau retrosser
les manches et ce que nous avez dit sur
la position française
notamment à Bruxelles est très
inquiétante et qu'on ne soit pas faire
de lance sur la création alors que on
est quand même je pense un pays un pays
phare pour ces sujets donc voilà je je
c'est vraiment sur l'optine les uns et
les autres et sur la rémunération des
des créateurs est-ce qu'il y a pas moyen
à ce moment-là puisque au final on ne
sait pas euh forcément euh euh quels
sont les droits d'auteur du produit fini
euh comment faire pour essayer de
peut-être rémunérer les auteurs euh
avant et et je sais que la musique en a
déjà réfléchi un peu sur la
question Monique
dearco merci
euh voilà je trouve ça ceci assez
inquiétant toutes vos pris de parole moi
je reviens euh donc sur une proposition
de loi que qui a été déposée à
l'Assemblée nationale en septembre
dernier qui est transpartisan qui vise à
modifier le code de la protection
intellectuelle pour introduire
uneobligation de consentement des
auteurs à l'exploitation de leurs œuvres
par les logiciel de l'IA voilà bon donc
je vous résume rapidement cette
proposition de loi que que j'ai vu je me
voulais vous poser la
question est-ce que cette proposition
vous semble aller dans le bon sens et
autrement quelle serait donc que ce que
pourriz apporter de complémentaire si
voilà sur cette proposition de loi de
façon à ce qu'éventuellement on puisse
après nous sans saisir au Sénat et et
l'améliorer enfin c'est une suggestion
dans la mesure où c'était trans
partisant ça pourrait être une
proposition de la Commission
Culture
éventuellement Sylvie Robert merci
monsieur le Président d'abord je
voudrais remercier vraiment l'ensemble
des intervenants pour leurs propos et
leur engagement et singulièrement ce sur
la position inquiétante de la France sur
le principe de la transparence je pense
que c'est extrêmement étonnant que
d'abord on puisse opposer innovation et
création alors même que dans le pays de
bon marché on pourrait en faire une
vraie valeur ajoutée donc ça c'est c'est
quand même extrêmement à la fois
inquiétant et étonnant j'aurais une
question liée à l'observation alors j'ai
entendu monsieur mayillard nous par
parler euh de c'est assez vertigineux
des milliers de de créations par
l'intelligence artificiel qui serait
d'ailleurs qui aurait dépassé le nombre
de notamment de photos je crois
euh créé en en l'espace de 50 ans est-ce
que dans les différents secteurs que
vous représentez vous avez pu estimer
les pertes finalement sèches subies par
les artistes auteurs de façon à pouvoir
alimenter aussi vraiment un un un propos
qui a merait à la nécessité d'encadrer
et de réguler l'intelligence
artificielle j'ai une question plus
précise vous ne serereit pas d'ailleurs
surpris surprise les créations générées
par l'assistance de l'IA vont poser des
difficultés de qualification notamment
pour joger de l'originalité de l'œuvre
et partant de l'empreinte de la
personnalité du créateur on sait et on
pressent qu'il va y avoir un travail
jurisprudentiel de dentelle je dis ça
parce que qui d'ailleurs a déjà déjà
commencé à à l'étranger selon vous où
doit-on placer le curseur pour octroyer
la protection du droit d'auteur à une
œuvre créée grâce à l'aide de l'IA
pensez-vous qu'il faille différencier le
droit d'auteur pour les œuvres créés à
partir d' nia ce que certains appellent
des œuvres augmentées du droit d'auteur
relatif au aux œuvres qui reflètent
vraiment l'expression humaine de la
créativité et de la personnalité de
l'auteur ça c'est une question précise
c'est vrai que j'ai déposé mais on a am
une position de là sur la preuve de
l'originalité de l'œuvre qui n'est
qu'une petite brique mais qui à mon avis
va avoir des conséquences sur la
réflexion que l'on pourra avoir sur
toutes ces questionsl et enfin j'ai une
demande de précision par rapport à
madame bensamoun vous
avez dit dans vos propos dans votre
propos liminaire que le principe de
prototypage ne serait pas intégré dans
le texte
euh j'aimerais bien que vous pré prcis
un peu votre propos et surtout nous dire
quelles conséquences ça a est-ce que
c'est directement lié au fait que parce
que la question du prototype et du cût
de ce qui est finalement créé en amont
ne serait pas pris en compte ça pose la
question fondamentale de voilà ce qui ou
alors ça a d'autres conséquences que je
ne perçois pas dans dans cette précision
j'aimerais bien que vous la vous la
précisie merci à à tous je voudrais de
mon côté poser deux questions
complémentaire d'abord sur la question
de l'optout et de son efficacité dans le
système actuel c'estàdire avec l'absence
de de transparence et de de sourçage
possible est-ce que c'est efficace ou
pas est-ce que je crois que la sasem l'a
déjà utilisé donc pouiez nous éclairer
un peu sur ce qui vous a motivé
motivation le comprend assez facilement
mais les résultats que que ça permet ou
pas dans l'état actuel de de législation
et et deuxème question dans dans le
prolagement de celle de de Monique dear
qui a cité une une PPL la question
s'adresse peut-être plus à Madame
Bamoun l'Union européenne est en train
de travailler sur une directri directive
pardon quels sont les champs législatifs
purement nationaux qui pourraent être d
dès à présent investiguer pour protéger
davantage des droits
d'auteur laisse répondre à peut-être
chacun en fonction des des questions
posées sur des éclairages que vous
pouvez nous apporter commençons par
Madame ben samon merci beaucoup merci
euh alors merci d'abord pour ces
questions tout à fait intéressante et et
très informé
visiblement
d'abord madame Maurin de sali est-ce que
le le trilogue est satisfaisant en
l'état alors vous le savez le le texte
définitif n'est pas encore sorti donc
nous n'avons pas le le le texte officiel
donc nous nous discutons sur des des
hypothèses il semblerait que
l'obligation qui est deux obligations
l'obligation de mettre en place des
mesures pour
respecter les droits des auteurs des
artistes interprètent donc voilà et y
compris de manière extraterritoriale
c'estàd quand on veut intégrer le marché
européen bah faut respecter les règles
du marché européen et puis une deuxième
obligation qui serait une obligation de
de transparence
des sources donc qu'est-ce qu'on a
utilisé dans sa base d'entraînement euh
euh ce qui pose beaucoup de
enfin a il y a des contestations sur
cette obligation de transparence parce
que certains certaines entreprises
considère que ça pourrait porter
atteinte au secret des affaires alors au
secret des affaires je ne le crois pas
parce que il s'agit pas de révéler les
traitements qui sont réalisés ou de
révéler des procédures mais uniquement
une liste de sources donc ça je je ne le
crois pas mais en revanche peut-être que
ça peut en effet avoir des conséquences
sur une stratégie commerciale ou et et
auquel cas ça peut se ça peut se régler
très facilement en passant par un/ers de
confiance donc je je crois que
l'argument qui dit la transparence ça
n'est pas possible parce que c'est
dangereux je crois qu'on peut le régler
de manière assez raisonnable sans sans
difficulté du coup je passe à à une
autre un autre élément qui est sans
doute en lien qui est sur la la
massification des données madame Daniel
où en effet vous avez raison les les
modèles de fondation sont entraînés sur
des masses et des masses de données et
et j'ai envie de répondre finalement à
cela que ce sont des professionnels de
la donnée qui ont l'habitude de traiter
des masses de données donc ça devrait
pas être euh inatteignable de de
proposer donc alors le le le texte
européen nous dit un résumé suffisamment
détaillé en tout cas d'orienter sur les
sources qui ont servi à l'entraînement
et de la part des titulaires de droit il
me semble mais là je peux pas vraiment
répondre pour eux je je parle uniquement
en mon nom aujourd'hui ni même au nom du
du comité de l'intelligence artificielle
he je je je le précise je je crois
savoir qu'il traite déjà des milliards
de lignes pour pouvoir opérer les
répartitions pour pouvoir faire les
vérifications et cetera donc je je crois
que aujourd'hui on est dans une société
de la donnée où on est appelé euh à
voilà à à traiter ces données donc je je
sais pas si c'est c'était le sens de
votre votre interrogation votre
interrogation à cette massification mais
je crois qu'on va progresser et on doit
progresser de toute façon le le
l'application du droit va passer par le
traitement de la donnée puisque nous
sommes dans une nous sommes entre
guillemets dataïsés si vous me permettez
ce terme qui n'existe pas et que
j'invente en direct voilà sur ce sur ce
sujet sur la
sur la science ouverte monsieuras
cherlore sur la science ouverte c'est un
sujet qui est très important qui qui est
beaucoup dans le dans le viseur de notre
de notre ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la Recherche Sylvie
rotaillot qui était mon mon ancienne
présidente d'université voilà et donc
c'est c'est un sujet qu'elle a à cœur
pour lequel elle a à cœur de de de
réfléchir et je sais pas si vous avez
participé contribué ce serait peut-être
utile
dans ces conditions il y a eu un rapport
du CSPLA du Conseil supérieur de la
propriété littéraire et artistique à la
demande du ministère de la culture et du
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
pour pouvoir
essayer voilà d'analyser la situation
c'est alors c'est je je n'étais pas dans
la je n'ai pasis pas du tout dans la
boucle de ce rapport mais à la dernière
plinière il a été présenté à la ministre
il y avait également les représentants
de l'enseigne de l'enseignement
supérieur et donc je crois qu'il serait
utile et si vous me le permettez je vais
me permettre de vous mettre en relation
avec le Conseil supérieur de la
propriété littéraire artistique pour que
vous puissiez contribuer à la mission et
éventuellement apporter également une
une contribution qui pourrait être mise
en ligne ou un renvoi peut-être au
rapport du Sénat donc voilà sur sur ce
ce
sujet madame Robert sur le sur la la
qualification en aval c'est un vrai suj
c'est un sujet en fait pour vous dire la
vérité qui va être beaucoup travaillé
par la doctrine et j'ai moi-même je je
commence à travailler sur ce sujet pour
une raison qui est il me semble que le
principe d'humanité de la création il
est essentiel d'abord il est
international il est partagé par
l'ensemble des États du monde peu ou
prou he mais mais on le tire en général
de la Convention de Berne 1886 la
convention qui fonde l'application du
droit d'auteur au niveau internation
nation donc c'est un sujet qui est
partagé on voit bien que l'US Copyright
Office comme les tribunaux américains
ont rejeté la qualification d'œuvre
lorsque l'auteur n'est pas un être
humain donc il y a il y a ce sujet très
important de la présence d'un être
humain parce que l'originalité c'est
quoi c'est l'empreinte de la
personnalité de l'auteur vous le savez
très bien et l'empreinte de la
personnalité de l'auteur c'est
nécessairement de manière subjective une
personne physique pour autant pour
autant à côté de ce principe d'humanité
de la création sur lequel on ne doit pas
il me semble très important de
comprendre que parfois l'intelligence
artificielle n'est qu'un outil entre les
mains d'un créateur qui va continuer à
marquer la création de l'empreinte de sa
personnalité si on ne le fait pas si on
est très radical en disant bah dès qu'on
utilise il a hop il y a une
disqualification qu'est-ce qu'on va
obtenir on va dissuader le secteur de la
création d'utiliser de l'intelligence
artificielle donc ça n'est pas
raisonnable on a déjà fait cette erreur
vous vous souvenez sans doute avec la
photographie le législateur français a
évolué dans sa position au départ il a
cru que l'utilisation
d'un d'un appareil et bien modifier les
conditions d'accès à la protection et
donc on a eu plusieurs lois pour dire
NON seul les les photographies
artistique et documentaire ou
documentaire on a essayé de de modifier
les choses en réalité lia peut tout à
fait être un outil entre les mains d'un
des créateurs et il y a des créateurs et
je vois des créateurs créés avec lia
c'est-à-dire s'augmenter en quelque
sorte comme on va tous le faire voilà
mais toujours en gardant la maîtrise de
l'outil et en marquant la création de
leur personnalité donc évidemment je je
veux pas vous dire que ça va être simple
il va y avoir une zone grise qui sera la
zone de qualification cette zone de
qualification c'est pas nouveau elle
appartient au juge elle a appartenu au
juge de tout temps et aujourd'hui encore
le juge nous dit est-ce que la boîte à
eux c'est une œuvre ou pas est-ce que
c'est suffisamment original est-ce que
cette armoire cette chaise c'est
suffisamment original c'est pas quelque
chose de nouveau c'est quelque chose qui
existe depuis l'origine du droit
d'auteur il va falloir sans doute aider
par un travail doctrinal comme ça a été
fait vous savez dans la dans vous vous
je sais que vous connaissez très bien ce
sujet je me permets donc l'arrê peiner
Eva Maria peayer hein de la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne où la Cour
de Justice a dégagé un certain nombre de
critères où on peut sur lesquel on peut
travailler pour dégager l'originalité
donc pour dégager l'empreinte de la
personnalité d'un auteur et je crois que
il faut qu'on fasse ce
travail sur l'originalité de manière
doctrinale et le juge va s'en saisir
aussi et lui aussi va travailler sur ce
sujet mais dans tous les cas la
qualification appartient au juge de
toute façon donc on ne peut pas lui
retirer cette qualification la
qualification c'est un travail
d'application du droit en revanche on
peut la accompagner travailler dessus
voilà et réfléchir et par notre
réflexion et bien aider à à ce travail
de qualification mais qui est de la
responsabilité des
juges sur en la votre deuxième question
et celle-là elle est vraiment à mon sens
très très importante et elle rejoint
aussi la question de de de Madame main
de sailli pour dire est-ce que le
trilogue est
satisfaisant le trilogue est
satisfaisant sur les obligations qui ont
été mises en place en lien avec
l'obligation de respect des des droits
en amont en lien avec l'obligation de
transparence je crois que c'est en effet
ça peut être considéré comme une
victoire ou en tout cas un un un progrès
voilà et et il faut s'en féliciter et il
faut aussi féliciter l'Union européenne
d'être parvenu à à à cela parce que le
c'est un c'est c'était un beau défi et
je crois qu'il a été relevé de ce point
de vue-là ensuite comme on n' pas
l'intégralité du texte vous savez que le
diable parfois dans les détails et il y
a cette définition qui m'interpelle la
définition à l'article 3 vous savez qu'
est l'article défini 3 définitoire comme
on trouve un peu dans tous les textes
européens au sens de ce texte il faut
entendre part et ces obligations de
respect et de transparence sont mises à
la charge de ce qu'on appelle les gpai
c'est-à-dire les les les systèmes d'IA à
usage général donc c'est ces gros
modèles he à usage général qu'ensuite on
va spécialiser peut-être mais ces gros
modèles tel qu'on les voit aujourd'hui
euh dans la définition désormais des des
gpai aurait été et j'utilise vraiment le
conditionnel parce que la version que
j'ai dans la version que j'ai a été
ajouté une phrase en fin de définition
pour
dire il faut on disqualifie de la donc
on retire la qualification de gpai en
phase de recherche de développement et
de
prototypage qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
veut dire ça veut dire que tout
simplement en facee de de construction
de l'outil bah les obligations qu'on
vient de rappeler l'obligation de
respect du droit d'auteur l'obligation
de transparence ne alors non je moi je
moi je mets un point d'interrogation je
dis ne s'appliquerait pas mais je je
comprendrait même pas en fait comment on
articule les deux dispositions puisque
ces obligations de transparence ont été
positionnées justement pour
l'entraînement et la constitution de ces
modèles et dans un article définitoire
on dirait bah non finalement eux ce sont
pas des gpai et donc du coup je je ne
sais pas comment articuler ces deux
dispositions c'est comme si on avait mis
en place des dispositions qu'on pouvait
exclure mais par l'amont je je voilà je
je ne sais pas et encore une fois pardon
hein mais c'est vraiment du conditionnel
parce que j'ai une version qui n'est
peut-être pas la version arrêtée en fin
de trilogue je voilà mais c'est un point
d'attention euh important sans aucun
doute je vous interroms là-dessus elle
sera rendu camp
offici alors ça c'est je je je je suis
pas en capacité nous n'avons pas cette
information il y a les réunions
techniques qui sont en cours il y a déjà
eu des réunions techniques moiant les
avant les
vacances de Noël réunions techniqu en
janvier et puis il y a deux trois
réunions par semaine à comptter du 15
janvier techniqu elles sont pas censé
remettre en cause les accords politiques
qui ont été adopt in non mais attendez
attendez le texte qui est sorti du
trilogue sur la question du trilogue
qu'on a qui est sorti du trilogue mais
qu'on n' pas il est probablement bon et
pourquoi il est bon parce que ceux qui
maintenant n'aiment pas la création qui
s'appelle monsieur barreau consort ont
dit qu'il était pas bon et qu'ils
allaient par des méthodes et des
discussions techniques et en particulier
ce que vient d'expliquer Alexandra c'est
très important essayer de sortir
euh l'entraînement une partie de
l'entraînement du dispositif de
protection voilà et c'est en train de se
jouer en ce moment et c'est pour ça que
nous nous sommes tous inquiets parce que
Thierry Breton franchement a fait un
très bon travail il s'est battu il a
d'ailleurs dit je le dis publiquement il
a dit les gfames et la start-up Mistral
ne défendent pas l'intérêt
général ça veut dire clairement que ils
ont dû lui faire du lobby sans cesse et
qu'il en a eu marre et qu' s'exprimait
publiquement voilà
donc c'est en ce moment qu'il faut être
extrêmement vigilant c'est en ce moment
qu'il faut exercer la pression maximum
sur le gouvernement français si en ce
moment d'ailleurs qu'il faudrait revoir
la composition de ce comité stratégique
où il n'y a qu'une seule défenseur de la
création elle est remarquable mais elle
est quand même toute
seule non mais c'est vrai je je je je
suis pas voilà je je suis pas titulaire
de droit tu défend le droit d'auteur et
et je alors je suis professeur de droit
je je suis spécialisée en propriété
intellectuelle et droit du numé
voilà je je je prends je prends ma part
dans ce comité mais je je ne représente
pas un intérêt dans ce comité oui mais
il y a aucun il y a des intérêts de la
tech il n'y a aucun intérêt entre
guillemets de la création en face c'est
tout voilà bon donc voilà sur sur la
phase trilogue on n pas les textes mais
en ce moment en ce moment jour et nuit
monsieur ceddrico et sa bande essae de
détcoter voilà la
vérité madame l Rumi oui je je voulais
dire parce que je n l'ai pas dit tout à
l'heure que effectivement nous au SEM on
a été impressionné par le travail fait
par le trilogue et que quand même c'est
un encouragement pour nous pourquoi
parce que les principes sont les
principes forts de transparence et de
respect des droits de la propriété
intellectuelle sont selon toute vraie
semblance et selon toutes les
informations qu'on a reconnu par ce
travail toutefois je je je je m'inquiète
et nous nous inquiétons fortement de
effectivement d'un détricotage par des
mesures techniques euh alors si le
diable est dans les détails
effectivement mais enfin un compromis
politique et un accord politique ne peut
pas être totalement rendu ineffectif par
un travail technique enfin nous
l'espérons il me semble mais ça reste à
à ben écoutez c'est c'est c'est très
préoccupant et et et on a peu de moyens
nous et on compte
sur sur vous tous pour notre pour
exercer un un devoir de vigilance sur ce
qui va se se passer il me semble qu'il y
a effectivement cette exception qui
pourrait en quelque sorte vider de sa
substance les beaux principes acquis
dans le texte donc l'exception gpai et
puis alors peut-être là c'est peut-être
une erreur mais j'entends parler aussi
d'exception pour les dispositifs en open
source qui propose de l'Open Source donc
ce serait donc une exception en fait à
la transparence à l'obligation de
transparence parce qu'il serait en open
source mais je je voulais dire que ça
n'a rien à voir que on ne voit
absolument pas pourquoi le système open
source qui effectivement il est il est
peut-être transparent sur son moteur
enfin sur le le code la ligne de code
mais il est pas transparent sur les
sources d'entraînement or nous il faut
le répéter ce qui importe c'est vraiment
en tout cas pour nous ce qui est
absolument cardinal c'est les
transparences la transparence sur les
sources d'entraînement voilà je ne
réponds pas aux autres questions du coup
je sais pas comment sorgan s absument
juste vraiment en un mot en effet tout
est bien qui finit bien pour autant que
ce soit fini et que la fin ne soit pas
ne soit pas modifié au
montage je voudrais revenir sur le sur
le trilogue sur un point décisif alors
bien évidemment on s'interroge sur la
transparence mais quand même des choses
qui ont été précisées c'est un vrai
progrès il n'y avait rien sur le droit
d'auteur et le trilogue a apporté une
disposition et il y a d'ailleurs des
considérants qui viennent expliquer les
effets du optout si on s'oppose à
l'utilisation de nos œuvres dans des
bases d'entraînement cela induit pour
les plateformes pour les outils la
nécessité d'aller contractualiser des
droits et de corriger la symétrie qui a
été évoqué tout à l'heure donc ça c'est
très important parce qu'on a le mode
d'emploi puis je dirais qu'il y a un
deuxième point qui est essentiel et ça
c'est un ajout à mon avis décisif c'est
que les fournisseurs d'intelligence
artificielle qu'ils entraînent le base
de données en France à Singapour ou au
Pérou s'ils opèrent sur le territoire de
l'Union Européenne devront se conformer
à la législation européenne il est
d'ailleurs précisé et je le cite aucun
fournisseur d'intelligence artificielle
ne doit être en mesure d'obtenir un
avantage concurrentiel sur le marché de
l'Union européenne en appliquant des
normes de droit d'auteur moins strictes
que celles prévu par le droit européen
et pour moi ça c'est un grand progrès
parce que si on crée un dispositif qui
n'est qu'appliqu que pour des actes
réalisés en Europe on va se retrouver
dans une situation qu'on connaît bien en
droit d'auteur c'est celle du forum
shopping o vous allez avoir des entités
mondialisées des entreprises
mondialisées qui vont aller opérer leur
activité ailleurs et qui vont venir
inonder le marché européens de leur
intelligigen artificielle donc là c'est
une réaction je dirais très saine de la
part de législateur européen d'avoir dit
écoutez si vous voulez évoluer sur le
marché européen conforme aux règles
alors maintenant j'entends bien je suis
aussi prudent que mes collègue sur la
réalité le détricotage le diable comme
le disait quelqu'un se cache dans les
détails je rappelle que sur l'obligation
de transparence et traçabilité des
contenus il va avoir une norme qui va il
y a une norme il y a un principe mais il
y aura un bureau de l'intelligence
artificielle qui va établir le modèle
donc là aussi il y aura une vraie
discussion et là les parlementaires
français pourront s'intéresser à ce que
est-ce que le modèle est suffisamment
satisfaisant pour permettre justement
aux aantroit de retracer l'utilisation
de leur contenu parce on va être face à
un problème très pratique estce qu'on
sera en capacité d'identifier nos
contenus quand ils sont utilisés pour
alimenter nourrir des intelligences
artificiel on reprend peut-être les
autres questions la question du contrôle
que vous avez un peu abordé législation
française oui nationale madame peut-être
alors sur l'articulation entre bah le
règlement qui est en train d'être adopté
et la la proposition de loi je je alors
je vais réserver certaines de mes
remarques aux députés que je vois demain
donc si vous voulez bien je voilà mais
euh on leur dira si vous voulez dans
dans dans dans tous les cas le le enfin
je crois qu' il y a quelque chose
d'important c'est que le règlement
constitue un progrès du point de vue du
droit d'auteur en tout cas dans ces
mesures de transparence si on a raison
sur sur notre
analyse cette proposition de loi sans
doute devra être adapté en considération
du règlement qui qui vous le savez
d'abord d'abord le le le droit européen
nous interdit de de de de d'adopter des
lois en phase de discussion d'un texte
européen sur les mêmes sujets donc ça on
a un devoir de de se
retirer et par ailleurs le règlement
européen va nous imposer un certain
nombre de dispositions et je crois que
donc il faudra sans aucun doute adapter
cette cette proposition mais qui est un
premier pas et qui va dans le bon sens
euh dans la mesure où ça marque
l'intérêt hein l'intérêt du Parlement
pour ces sujets de droit d'auteur et de
droits voisins du droit d'auteur donc il
me semble que c'est une démarche qui est
positive et qui demandera à être adapté
en considération de du du règlement
alors le règlement européen est
directement applicable il n'a pas à être
transposé mais comme pour le rgpd on
pourra très bien dans la loi nationale
en faisant référence au règlement et
bien
adapter ajouter peut-être quelques
dispositions dans dans le dans le le
Code de la propriété intellectuelle et
aussi peut-être s'imisser dans des
endroits qui ne sont pas réglementés par
le le règlement européen pense à quoi
euh ben le sujet on est en train de
discuter on a dit il y a aussi le sujet
de l'aval qui qui qui interroge donc
voilà on peut s'interroger est-ce que
c'est le moment est-ce que c'est un peu
trop tôt je crois qu'on a encore besoin
de réfléchir un peu hein sur la
qualification en avant mais il est
peut-être temps d'étudier l'ensemble des
solutions qui qui seraient
possible après il y a peut-être d'autres
aspects très pratiques sur l'optout
est-ce qu'on peut pas préciser un petit
peu les choses ce qu'on a ce qu'on avait
fait en 2021 est-ce que on n pas besoin
peut-être de le remettre un petit peu à
jour et et là on aurait le véhicule qui
serait adéquate pour le faire tout ça
relève d'une même logique finalement
c'est l'intelligence artificielle
et la création culturelle donc on peut
très bien aussi revenir un petit peu
réaménager des dispositions qu'on a
écrite au moment où l' générative à la
disposition du grand public n'existait
pas monsenir parce que c'est une
question fondamentale il y a quand même
un interstice et il y a de la place pour
le législateur
national on parlait de l't aujourd'hui
le législateur français pas passé devant
le Parlement a étit par voir
d'ordonnance il a transposé il a fait un
copier-collé de ce que dit la directive
de 2019 et la directive de 2019 sur les
modalités de mise en œuvre de l'optout
je peux pas dire que ce soit d'une
limpidité voilà on vous dit par des
moyens approprié comme si on allait
mettre des moyens non appropriés ou de
manière expresse comme si on allait dire
implicitement ce qu'on voulait quand on
le veut vis-à-vis de gens qui ont
beaucoup de puissance enfin c'est quand
même pas très cohérent donc moi je pense
que il y a matière à légiférer surtout
que quelqu'un je crois que c'est Thierry
l'a dit de manière très claire pas les
auteurs qui diffusent des œuvres ce sont
les plateformes aujourd'hui qui
diffusent les heures ou les diffuseurs
traditionnels et donc moi j'ai beau dire
ça s je veux un optout je veux que mes
doigs mes droits soient restaurés
respectés pour pouvoir faire de l'optin
pour pouvoir liciter et rémunérer mes
créateurs mais si les plateformes ne le
mettent pas en place vous allez avoir
des outils d' intelligence artificielle
qui vont venir piller les contenus et
les insérer dans leur boîte noire c'est
exactement comme ça que ça va se passer
donc il y a il y a une responsabilité
spécifique je pense qu'il faut un peu
étudier parce que à l'époque on avait
pas le recul suffisant faut aussi le
reconnaître aujourd'hui on a un peu plus
de recul on a des experts comme
Alexandra qui se penche sur la question
on a aussi un retour d'expérience
pratique et il va falloir organiser la
responsabilité des plateforme sur la
mise en œuvre de cet optout qui n'est en
réalité que la traduction du respect des
droits d'auteur c'est juste une
déclinaison du respect des droits
d'auteur donc je pense qu'elles ont un
rôle majeuri une plateforme je vais la
citer comme YouTube j'ai rien contre
YouTube on un accord avec eux mais
aujourd'hui c'est la plus grande base de
données de musique vous avez tout vous
avez toutes les sorties même les titres
qui ne sont n'ont pas été commercialisés
si cette plateforme n'organise pas
l'optout de manière efficace et ne
protège pas l'intégrité des données elle
va être pillée elle sera elle pourra
développer des outils mais surtout elle
servira de cible donc c'est absolument
essentiel que cette ne soit pas qu'un
qu'une possibilité théorique et que les
plateformes aient une responsabilité eu
égard à la volonté exprimée par les
titulaires de droit monsieur Mayard
oui donc sur l'optout je suis tout à
fait d'accord et sur le fait aussi qu'on
a sans doute une marche de de manœuvre
au niveau national puisque je pense
qu'il y a d'autres moyens que d'aller
pister chaque site pour avoir des
procédés disibles par la par la machine
et je voulais revenir également sur
alors sur la question de l'optin qui
serait effectivement pour nous l'idée là
pour le coup l'optine il me semble
nécess ce sera un retour au droit
exclusif pur c'està-dire plus
d'exception donc là il faudrait
supprimer cette exception donc ça on
part sur quelque chose qui est beaucoup
plus long en revanche on peut avoir donc
cet aménagement de de looptout dans la
proposition de loi sur laquelle
Alexandre ne peut pas parler nous notre
point de vue c'est que c'est tous les
les sujets sont mis sur quoi un grand
nombre de sujets très importants sont
mis sur la table la difficulté c'est la
manière dont ils sont appréhendés ou
d'un point de vue léistique et puis de
d'efficacité de des mesures et même de
de cohérence avec la la réalité ça ça
colle pas par exemple de prévoir une
cotitularité des droits pour pour toutes
les œuvres générées par les contenus
générés par Ia on parle peut-être de de
dizaines ou de centaines de millions
d'auteurs qui potentiellement pourraent
être impliqué là-dedans et puis de la
même manière la transparence on parle
beaucoup de transparence et c'est
effectivement c'est le préalable à tout
c'està-dire c'est le préalable à
l'optout à la rémunération donc si on
n'a pas de transpar on fera rien
derrière je pense qu'il faut quand même
qu'on parle des autres sujets également
pour savoir une fois qu'on a la
transparence qu'on en fait et la
transparence c'est également sur sur ce
qui est créé par par les par les IA et
ça rejoint la question de savoir est-ce
qu'on sait estimer les pertes
aujourd'hui on sait pas estimer les
perte puisqu'on ne sait pas ce qui est
les personnes ne revendique sauf
quelques opérateurs qui font des œuvres
générées par a donc pour l'instant c'est
dilué le la couverture du monde dont je
parlais elle est absolument pas créditée
comme étant généré par par intelligence
artifici
donc la la la la PPL qui dit que on va
devoir mettre sous chaque contenu la
liste de tous les auteurs qui ont été
intégrés là-dedans on parle de dizaines
de millions d'auteurs potentiellement
donc là il y a il y a une difficulté
mais je pense que de la même manière sur
la transparence dans l'output on
pourrait avoir également une obligation
de de d'avoir des procédés lisibles par
la machine pour savoir qu'une œuvre a
été générée par et j'aimerais juste
revenir sur sur votre question madame
Robert sur le la question de de l'aval
et de la la protection de ces d'œuvre et
le lien avec l'originalité c'est quelque
chose finalement qu'on connaît déjà nous
dans le secteur des des arts graphiques
et plastiques notamment avec l'art
contemporin on a énormément d'auteurs
qui n'interviennent pas directement sur
la forme des ulvres mais qui posent un
protocole et qui laisse ensuite des
machines ou la nature faire quelque
chose si je prends les anthropométries
de clin bah c'est pas clin qui peint
directement sur la toile ça va être les
modèles qui va dans la mise en scène qui
vont aller se mettre sur la toile quand
on a les expansions de Césars c'est des
produits chimiques qui vont créer la de
l'œuvre on s'en est toujours sorti en
matière de droit d'auteur parce qu'on a
une présomption de titularité de droit
pour celui qui divulgue l'œuvre sous son
nom et ça ça fonctionne très bien dans
notre secteur donc si ça se trouve à la
dagp on a déjà des auteurs qui utilisent
de l'intelligence artificielle comme
super outil et ça c'est une chose qu'il
faut conserver et avoir une une
appréhension des règles du droit
d'auteur qui soit raisonnable dans dans
la manière et qu'on on refuse pas la
protection à quelqu'un qui utilise des
outils pour parce qu'il a un projet
créatif et qui sait où il veut
intervenir mais donc donc le critère
c'est celui de l'intervention décisive
de l'auteur dans la création dans la
forme de la création mais inversement il
y a un problème si jamais on a des
œuvres qui sont générés par Ia qui sont
revendiqués comme générés par la machine
uniquement c'està-dire sans aucune aucun
créateur qui est intervenu en amont et
sur ces œuvresl c'est elle qui crée un
préjudice économique très fort pour les
auteurs et c'est elle qu'il faudrait
handicaper d'une certaine manière c'est
pour ça que on trouve intéressant la
question de du domaine public payant qui
ferait que il faut faire en sorte que ce
qui est généré par de la machine et qui
n'est pas attribué à une personne
physique ne puisse pas venir
concurrencer les les œuvres qui sont
créés par des auteur personne physique
donc il faut trouver tous les moyens et
l'intérêt de ces choseslà c'est pour ça
il y a sans doute plein d'autres
dispositifs qui peuvent être envisagé
l'intérêt du domaine public payant par
exemple c'est que ça ne relève pas de la
directive de 2019 parce qu'on est sur
quelque chose qui n'est pas protégeable
par le droit d'auteur si c'est
uniquement la machine qui a créé et
qu'on n pas d'auteur derrière qui l'
encadré de mon point de vue on peut
intervenir sans avoir à à demander
l'avis du législateur dès lors qu'on
n'est pas dans le domaine du droit
d'auteur je vois que Alexandra est
réservé là-dessus mais
oui oui deux mots pour revenir sur la
question de des modalités d'exercice et
et l'effectivité de de de l'optout euh
en ce qui concerne pardon l'option
d'exclusion du droit
d'opposition du droit d'opposition du
droit du droit d'opposition non mais je
je
euh en ce qui concerne les éditeurs de
livres alors on n pas tout à fait dans
des situations juridiques équivalentes
autour de la table en ce qui concerne la
capacité à exprimer ou exercer un droit
d'opposition collectif mais la position
elle est elle est elle est très claire
et et elle a été énoncée au début de
cette année avec une recommandation
généralisée d'exercice généralisé du
droit d'opposition une
précision pas parce que les éditeurs de
livres sont vcéralement opposé à quelque
utilisation que ce soit des contenus
pour entraîner un jour et entrer dans
des processus de de d'intelligence
artificielle tout simplement parce qu'à
l'heure actuelle nous n'avons pas la
protection qui est nécessaire et qu'on
est dans une situation de défiance qui
est le principal frein à l'innovation le
le fait que dans les acteurs de cette
chaîne on soit en situation de de de de
de d'avoir ce que ce cette absence de
confiance voir évidemment ce climat de
défiance est un élément qui est un frein
beaucoup plus fort que que d'autres
freins qui ont été qui ont été énoncé
alors en ce qui concerne après
l'effectivité euh c'est effectivement
très difficile dans l'état actuelle des
choses parce qu'il manque dans le
dispositif quand même un point qui me
paraît essentiel c'est le fait que pèse
sur ceux qui vont chercher des données
une forme de de d'obligation de
diligence raisonnable d'aller rechercher
qui a pu exercer un droit d'opposition
quelque part qu'on aille pas nous dire
que parce qu'on a vu 10 pages d'un livre
sur le site d'une maison de presse
l'éditeur a donné son consentement voilà
et encore une fois on est face à des
géants de la technologie le fait qu'il
reconnaissent ces ces extr trait qui
vont circuler de droite et de gauche
vont êre accompagn de de de référence
c'est pas très compliqué de se de de de
de conclure que si droit d'opposition il
y a il a été exprimé peut-être davantage
sur le site de l'éditeur que sur le site
de la Maison de la presse alors la
solution à terme elle a été énoncée
c'est effectivement certainement d'avoir
un tir de confiance parce que c'est ce
qui permettrait à la fois de satisfaire
les deux conditions qui ont été évoquées
à savoir effectivement le fait que ça
soit on n' pas besoin de savoir qui
utilise quoi pour faire quoi donc le
secret des opérateurs et puis le fait
qu'il y ait un un un recueil centralisé
euh de de de de ce droit de ce droit
d'opposition euh faute de quoi euh les
les les titulaires de droit vont
s'épuiser avec des solutions techniques
avec des propagations euh de de droit
d'opposition dans l'ensemble des
réutilisateur de données euh le le
combat n'est pas mené dans la bonne
direction si s'il part sur ces
bases-là ouais non mais moi j'ai
l'impression que l'histoire se répète
parce que l'histoire des droits d'auteur
est du numérique ça commence toujours
par la piraterie alors et là la grande
différence c'est que la piraterie elle a
été toujours condamnée par le
gouvernement français et on a eu
d'ailleurs un président de la République
c'était Nicolas Sarkozi qui qui vraiment
a essayé de mettre en œuvre des
dispositions très forte pour lutter
contre la piraterie et maintenant on a
un gouvernement qui défend des
entreprises qui veulent tout simplement
pirater c'est assez simple bon euh en ce
qui concerne les les questions qui ont
été posé efficacité l'optout pour le
moment on fait plutôt de la
communication que de la réalité il faut
être clair bon parce qu'on est on est
très en amont des de de ce qui va
arriver mais on a quand même intérêt à
communiquer sur
euh alors je dirais pas optin je sais
pas autorisation voilà pour parler
français faire plaisir à Jacques Toubon
euh je dirais que on voit des choses
arriver c'estàdire que là j'ai lu qu'il
y avait un accord qui avait été passé
entre openi et le groupe Springer donc
ça veut dire très clairement que si on
veut respecter le droit d'auteur rentrer
dans un cadre légal bah on peut le faire
après a été soulevé la question de la
multiplicité des ayants droit par
rapport à des grandes entreprises on
sait faire on a des systèmes de gestion
collective laassasem a énormément de
membres la SACD en a beaucoup et ça nous
a posé aucun problème pour négocier des
accords avec Amazon Netflix etut c'est
plus compliqué avec les Chinois de ktok
on y est pas encore arrivé je remercie
le Sénat d'avoir fait une commission
d'enquête mais on a du mal à avancer
mais voilà donc on est dans dans un
monde où à chaque fois on réinvente ce
qu'on a déjà traité depuis depuis très
longtemps et il suffit en tout cas ce
que je souhaite et c'est pour ça que
c'est un appel politique je souhaite que
la France reste ferme sur ces principes
et soit toujours le premier défenseur de
la protection des cré des artistes
interprètes des entreprises de presse
avec le droit voisin et que ce soit
toujours ce combat qu'elle a mené
qu'elle a toujours gagné et on va pas
renoncer pour faire gagner quelques
centimes à Monsieur cedrico c'est tout
j'ai l'impression que c'est plus que
quelques centimes mais oui je rle madame
lorimi et ensuite madame
oui je je vous
remerci en ce qui concerne en ce qui
concerne les approches des différentes
approche juridique ou judiciaire euh il
a été fait référence tout à l'heure à la
disymétrie des forces en présence
notamment dans les contentieux et
possibles et je je voulais rappeler que
nous on a éprouvé cette diymétrie de
façon extrêmement forte puisque euh en
2020 on a commencé un contentieux avec
la société Google pour faire appliquer
notre droit voisin euh je voulais dire
aussi que ce contentieux il a abouti à à
de
deux de deux choses importantes d'abord
une condamnation assez forte 500
millions d'euros de la société Google
pour non
respect qui qui ne respectait pas le
droit voisin et qui a abusé de de sa
position dominante vis-à-vis des
éditeurs de presse donc une amende
lourde d'une part et puis aussi après
des conditions et là on arrive au au
point de l'OPT in aux conditions de
négociation qui sont même si elles sont
pas parfaites qui sont plus faciles avec
ces géants c'està-dire
des conditions de négociation qui sont
qui interviennent après une décision de
l'Autorité de la concurrence là en
l'occurrence et donc je j'en venais à
ces questions de de
de de de de contentieux ou de de de
droit applicable on est passé un peu
vite sur ce que Monsieur Thierry Mayard
a dit tout à l'heure et je crois qu'il
était
également madame la professeur aussi
dans votre article dans Le dalos qui
était l'application ou non de cette
exception qui en effet a été euh a été
élaborée a été pensée à une époque où
soit li a n'existait pas soit elle était
vraiment très très balbuciante et où on
n'imaginait pas la destruction de valeur
en tout cas je parle pour le secteur de
la presse on ne pouvait pas imaginer la
destruction de valeur qui allait s'en
suivre euh et et et les problèmes euh
même plus larges que que que cette
exploitation allait causer par rapport à
une exploitation normale euh euh qu'on
doit pouvoir retrouver selon le test en
trois étapes donc sur cette question
d'exception moi je nous on ne souhaite
pas aller trop vite on souhaite explorer
tous les champs on souhaite réfléchir à
tous les moyens juridiques que nous
avons euh et donc parmi les moyens
juridiques il y a bien évidemment euh la
propriété intellectuelle euh bien sûr
mais il y a aussi un champ que nous donc
on a on a pu euh on a pu pratiquer
beaucoup qui est le droit de la
concurrence
euh alors il y a euh le droit de la
concurrence il est on peut on peut
évoquer le droit de la concurrence
euh euh français européens les autorités
françaises les autorités européennes euh
qui s'exerce donc à postériori lorsqu'il
y a eu une atteinte au droit de la
concurrence notamment un abus de
position dominante ou une entente et
cetera et cetera et puis aujourd'hui et
je pense qu'il faut qu'on étudie cet
outil làà on a également le DMA qui est
entré en vigueur progressivement au
cours de l'année 2023 la la Commission a
déterminé une liste alors évidemment
elle est contestée mais une liste de
gatekeeper très grandes plateformes qui
sont soumis à un certain nombre comment
oui qui sont soumis à qui sont soumises
pardon à un certain nombre d'obligations
donc voilà nous auosm donc les éditeurs
on de press magazine on est dans la
l'approfondissement de de notre propre
connaissance parce que tout ça est assez
nouveau appris un petit peu tout le
monde de cours euh
l'approfondissement de notre doctrine
juridique euh qui se doit à ce stade
pour nous d'être très ouverte euh donc à
la fois propriété intellectuelle à la
fois euh à la fois droit de la
concurrence avec l'idée qu'il faut
impérativement restaurer les auteurs euh
pardon les éditeurs dans leur droit
d'autoriser ou non c'est-à-dire
éventuellement de bloquer il peut y en
avoir certains qui ne veulent pas
partager euh euh l'exclusivité des des
des articles et puis le droit euh
d'autoriser euh euh la reproduction pour
céder et pour se voir rémunérer euh dans
les cas et là on cite la le l'accord qui
s'est produit en Allemagne effectivement
donc un accord direct entre l'éditeur
Axel Springer et euh et euh et
l'opérateur de d'intelligence
artificielle je dois dire qu'on ne sait
pas he ce qu'il y a dans cet accord on
sait pas exactement sur quoi il est
fondé et cetera donc il y a il y a
encore beaucoup d'inconnus euh mais oui
au SEPM nous nous nous notre priorité
aujourd'hui va être de donner le choix
aux éditeurs en effet soit de bloquer ce
qui pour l'instant n'est pas réellement
possible on pourra y revenir he l'optout
et les
blocages il y a énormément de questions
de surblocage de sousblocage de
conséquences sur le référencement il y a
beaucoup de questions que pose l'optout
ou le blocage même technique donc soit
le blocage soit effectivement une
rémunération comme tout comme tout
effectivement tout travail effectué tout
produit acheté intervention très courte
al que c'est très très court je voulais
juste souligner que c'est laacil
normalement qui va être chargé de
contrôler l'application des systèmes Ia
laquel knil est remise en cause par
votre certains membres du comité
intergouvernmental dont ceddrico mais
aussi un certain Gill Babinet sans doute
qui devant le Sénat la délégation à la
prospective a déclaré que il fallait en
finir en quelque sorte avec avec lacil
parce que ça bridait l'innovation mais
je tiens quand même à le dire parce que
on a à combattre contre des esprit qui
oppose transparence
innovation voilà ce qui est une inepsie
totale voilà pourquoi il refuse sans
doute d'être auditionné par notre
commission donc je tenais quand même à
le dire parce qu'il y a ce sujet là
aussi de la knil qui est remise en cause
alure
actuel alors je
je je à nouveau hein je je je ne réponds
pas du euh du comité de l'intelligence
artificielle je voilà je mais comme
comme professeur de droit je je je je
dis toute l'importance de respecter euh
les droits de manière générale que ce
soit le droit de propriété qui est un
droit fondamental le droit à la
protection des données personnelles qui
est aussi un droit fondamental et qui
nous engage c'est-à-dire qui nous engage
de manière internationale dans des
conventions internationales et qui nous
engag au niveau européen au sein de
l'Union européenne donc dans tous les
cas euh enfin voilà je je crois que euh
là-dessus je je je il me semble
important de rappeler aussi que
l'intelligence artificielle est une
chance et que pour autant elle ne peut
pas enfin son son son développement et
son déploiement ne peut pas se faire en
rognant sur d'autres droits fondamentaux
c'est c'est un équilibre et le droit est
toujours à faire d'équilibre de toute
façon sauf à postuler que le législateur
pas par définition est des raisonnable
ce que je ne crois pas le droit est
toujours une question
d'équilibre en tout cas je je je ne le
crois pas alors très très très
rapidement pour pour en finir avec le
débat sur l'exception pas l'exception
est-ce qu'elle s'applique est-ce est-ce
qu'elle ne s'applique pas j'ai envie de
dire un jour on le saura parce qu'un
juge nous le dira mais ce jour il est
très long loin et il y a urgence à agir
et donc il y a urgence à améliorer les
conditions de l'optout à développer
l'efficacité et l'effectivité de
l'optout dans cette attente qu'un jour
peut-être on nous dise et on aura plus
de recul on nous dise et que la Cour de
justice nous dise donc dans cette
attente je crois qu'il faut mobiliser
tout ce qu'on peut mobiliser l'optout le
DMA le droit de la concurrence je crois
que ce sont des outils qu'on doit
mobiliser pour
sécuriser le marché enfin peut-être pour
conclure ce ce cette cet entretien cette
audition on peut dire je crois que le le
le refus de manière générale le refus de
se soumettre au au droit le refus de
transparence le qu'est-ce que ça suscite
et bien tout simplement ça crée des
crispations ça crée une défiance avec
une conséquence qui est le le droit
d'opposition généralisé l'exercice
généralisé d'un droit d'opposition ce
qui n'est un pas pas agréable pour
personne c'est-à-dire ni pour les
titulaires de droit qui ne sont pas là
pour retenir leur contenu mais au
contraire pour les valoriser je crois
que enfin je dire les les créateurs ne
créent pas juste pour la beauté du geste
mais parce qu'ils en vivent également et
donc ça crée cette crispation d'exercer
un optout généralisé alors que les
titulaires de droit aimeraient au
contraire valoriser leur contenu et puis
ça a des conséquences des effets de bord
très négatifs sur la diffusion de la la
culture française parce qu'on exerce
l'optout donc les les la culture
française ne sera pas intégrée à cette
intelligence artificielle et je ne dis
pas qu'il faut forcer hein le le trait
je dis sous sous réserve du respect des
droits la culture française doit aussi
par par souci de diversité culturelle et
de de rayonnement aussi de la culture
française elle doit intégrer ces
systèmes d'IA enfin je je crois que si
on doit retenir un maître mot c'est euh
pour susciter la confiance il faut des
solutions équilibrées je crois que le le
secret c'est ça c'est l'équilibre c'est
le respect d'une certaine chaîne de
valeur voilà quand on aura atterri dans
une position équilibrée je crois que
tout le monde l'acceptera je me souviens
très bien des débats qu'on avait sur
l'article 17 moi quand j'allais dans les
capitales européennes ou à Bruxelles
pour défendre le texte je regardais mes
pieds parce queil y avait des panneau
publicitaire save your internet j'avais
l'impression d'être un grand bandit euh
je je je crois qu'aujourd'hui les les
choses se sont adouci calmé parce qu'on
a atterri sur une position équilibrée et
que c'est ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse
aujourd'hui il est hors de question il
est pas plainte non mais n disait que
c'it une atteinte aux liberté
fondamentale micro parce que pr l'arcom
est censé recueillir les plaintes des
utilisateurs qui auraient vu leur
contenu bloquer injustement ça fait 4
ans que le dispositif est en place donc
vous avez une entité vous avez un
mécanisme prévu par les plateformes tout
est très simple un point de vue de
l'utilisation zéro plainte non mais
relisez en 2017 2018 2019 l'hystérie
autour de la mise en œuvre de l'article
17 pour une fois que l'article a été
transposé et 4 ans après on a quand même
un peu de recul zéro
plainte
voilà tout est dit merci beaucoup pour
votre accueil merci beaucoup à chacun
d'entre vous c'est vous étiez très clair
je crois que ça a nettement permis à une
meilleure compréhension de la part de de
la Commission et de nos oreilles
raisonnables de de des enjeux que sont
que peuvent poser les l par rapport à à
la création et nous ne manquerons pas
certainement de vous resolliciter dans
les semaines et les mois à venir merci
beaucoup